Gleisdreieck.
Da bin ich jetzt auf dem kalten Fuß. Es kann da aber genau an dieselbe Stelle rein, weil das Feld, was sie dafür benutzen, wo sie die zwei Bits alle ziehen, gibt es auch in V6. Es könnte sein, dass sie das auf dieselbe Art und Weise machen, dieselben zwei Bits benutzen.
Was sind mit diesen Bits? Warum waren die denn frei?
Das sind Bits, wo man so Class-of-Service-Priority-Geschichten rein macht. Das ist ein 8-Bit-Feld und da kann man durchaus mal zwei für so etwas opfern. Doch, wird benutzt. Wird sogar inzwischen häufig benutzt. Hatte ich glaube ich schon mal erwähnt, diese komische Hybridroute und so etwas benutzt man auch von der Telekom.
Aber weißt du dich das dann nicht damit?
Weil man hat 8, also sind 8 Bits dafür da, aber man macht heutzutage keine Klassifikationen in 256 verschiedene Traffic Classes. Sondern man hat so 3, 4 große und davon 1, 2.
Also man hat nicht Bits genommen, sondern hat sozusagen 2 Werte von diesen 256 sich geschätzt.
Nein, man hat 2 Bits genommen. Weil es gibt da 4 States von dem Zeug. Aber man hat gesagt, okay, wir kommen immer noch mit 6 Bits super klar, um damit unser Class of Service Definition einen ausreichenden Ausdruck zu verleihen.
Also sie haben sozusagen den 8-Bit-Wert auf einen 6-Bit-Wert degradiert und die beiden Bits zweckentfremde.
So, und wie gesagt, das ist ein Mechanismus, der schon länger drin ist. Er erzählt auch so schön, selbst auch für den Mitbewerb, er erzählt also auch seit wann Windows das schon drin hat. Also zumindest muss man ja immer sehen, es gibt eine passive Seite davon, es gibt eine aktive Seite. Und er sagt, also Windows hat das schon lange drin, ist aber defaultmäßig aus und so. Und Linux hat das seit dann und dann drin. Und wir haben das da drin und passiv. Und jetzt machen wir das einfach mal an. Das finde ich, wie gesagt, eine sehr interessante Geschichte. Das müssen aber, wie gesagt, alle mitspielen. Oder viele mitspielen.
Naja, es reicht aber, wenn auch nur der mitspielt, der jetzt am aktivsten davon betroffen ist, weil es schon gewährleistet ist, dass wenn, sagen wir mal, jetzt schon die Fritzbox stöhnt, so beim ersten oder zweiten Hopp, und die da den Stempel reinsetzt, dann bleibt dieser Wert auf jeden Fall auch erhalten über andere Router, selbst wenn die dieses Problem ignorieren.
Ja, außer du hast dahinter nochmal einen Router, der nochmal langsamer ist als die Fritzbox.
Der?
Unlikely, aber kann er sein.
Ja, was kann der dann?
Der kann noch weiter runterbremsen.
Ja gut, aber dann setzt er ja auch nur den Stempel da rein und sagt...
Ja, aber er setzt ihn häufiger.
Achso, ja gut, aber worauf ich hinaus wollte ist, es muss nicht die ganze Kette unterstützen, damit es überhaupt funktioniert, sondern die betroffenen Router müssen es jeweils unterstützen, damit es irgendwo funktioniert.
Da stehen aber endlich bei deinem Provider. Und wo wieder das Problem da ist, da musst du halt eben hingehen, so einer Telekom mal sagen, hallo bitte eure so viel 100B-Rasse, die ihr habt, bundesweit, könnt ihr die mal in Ordnung bringen?
Und denkst du, dass die auch häufig der Grund sind, dass die Router im Netz...
Es hängt von der Senderichtung ab. Du kannst da immer nur als Router beeinflussen, was du selber raussendest. Du hast ja keinen Einfluss darauf, was der drüben dir über die Leitung schickt. Weil in dem Moment, wo du das siehst, ist es ja schon durch die Leitung durch. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt ein Problem hast in Upstream-Richtung, das heißt, du sendest was weg, wie wir jetzt hier aus der Meta-Ebene über deinen tollen VDSL-Anschluss, da könnten wir, wenn wir jetzt wahnsinnig fette Streams hier erzeugen würden, oder gleichzeitig irgendwie Huckel noch ein Upload machen würden auf seinen Server oder sowas, da kann jetzt der Router hier eingreifen und die Systeme intern ausbremsen. Wenn du aber in Download-Richtung Probleme hast, dann ist der Router, der vor dem Bottleneck steht, der Behras von deinem ISP in DSL-Anschluss oder wie auch immer. Das heißt, der muss das machen, der muss dann den Sender ausbremsen, der gegebenenfalls in der Antarktis steht. Also da müssen schon ein paar Leute mehr mitspielen. Aber man muss jetzt nicht das ganze Backbone umrüsten, weil die haben in der Regel das nicht, sondern das sind halt eher so Excess-Router alle und halt eben die Plastikboxen bei den Usern draußen. Aber wie gesagt, jemand durchbricht jetzt mal die Kette, indem er jetzt einfach mal sagt, ich mach das jetzt mal an. So, jetzt seid ihr dran.
Also vor allem Apple macht das halt an, insofern, als dass sie mit den Rückmeldungen leben können. Das ist sozusagen das, was sie anmachen.
Das könntest du sowieso schon, aber du musst explizit sagen, dass du das gerne machen willst. Das heißt, du musst explicit, congestion notification musst du sagen, ich bin sozusagen in der Lage, mit den Rückmeldungen zu leben.
Also eine Bit sagt, ich kann das, und das andere Bit ist, wenn sie sagen, jetzt ist es voll.
Genau.
Und das gibt es schon immer und ist nichts Apple-spezifisches oder so, sondern seit 2001, RFC und so weiter. Und die Firewalls dürfen auch das Bit da nicht löschen, so wie viele das so machen.
Schaut euch den Vortrag an, er zeigt sehr schön auch mit Grafiken, was da passiert, und er macht sozusagen, so sieht ein Datenstrom aus, so wenn sich der Buffer aufbläht, der Buffer sieht, er macht das richtig grafisch auch mit einem Tool. Und dann macht er halt den Gegentest, sagt so, wir machen jetzt mal ECL an, und jetzt schaut mal, wie schön das hier rauscht. Das finde ich auch sehr gut erklärt von dem Namen.
Genau, dritte Sache, die er vorgestellt hat, um Delays zu reduzieren, war so Low Water Mark Modus für Netzwerkshockets. Seilenbeispiel war, und das kennt man glaube ich auch, dass man so Screensharing macht auf seinen Heimrechner. Dann hängt man natürlich dann auch im Upload-Kanal von seinem DSL fest. Und dann hat man halt so späte Rückmeldungen, aber vor allem, man macht so irgendeine Bewegung und dann dauert es mehrere Sekunden, dann wird die immer so nachgezeichnet und man kann halt stundenlang den Fenstern dabei zuschauen, wie sie irgendwie ihre Kreise ziehen.
In dem Video hat er ein schönes Beispiel. Er simuliert so eine Session, so eine runtergedämpfte Session zwischen zwei Rechnern, nimmt mit der Maus so ein Fenster, fährt so ein bisschen mit der Maus auf den Bildschirm rum, dann springt er weg von seinem Terminal, nimmt die Hände hoch und das Fenster hüpft immer noch auf seinen Bildschirm rum.
Die Buffer sind zu groß und dann alles replayed wird sozusagen, weil die Leitung war nicht schnell genug, der Buffer war aber voll und dann dauert es eine Weile, bis es dadurch ist. Eigentlich könnte man die ganzen Bilder, die noch im Buffer liegen, die zu viel waren und die viel zu lange brauchen, wegschmeißen und das aktuelle Bild senden, wenn man weiß, das erste ist jetzt angekommen.
Genau.
Problem verstanden, die Lösung nicht.
War ja noch keine Lösung dabei.
Du hast gesagt, man könnte ja dann die wegschmeißen und so. Er sagt, die wegschmeißen, sondern gar nicht erst senden.
Also gleich den Buffer klein machen.
Nee, gar nicht erst den Buffer füllen. Und das geht natürlich nur, wenn du eine Rückmeldung vom Netzwerksdeck bekommst, darüber, was auch tatsächlich versendet wurde oder werden kann. Das habe ich jetzt nicht so ganz verstanden.
Also jetzt ist es so, dass normalerweise, im Betriebssystem hast du in deinem Socket einen Buffer drin. Das heißt, du siehst als Applikation gar nicht, wie schnell der nach draußen sendet. Du kannst erstmal da etliche 100 Kilobyte in diesen Socket reinprügeln, ohne dass die Applikation jetzt merkt, dass die jetzt wie nur langsam hinten rauskleckern. Und was er jetzt gemacht hat, ist, da die meisten Applikationen ihren Socket irgendwie pollen, mit welchem Systemcall auch immer, ob nur Select oder Poll oder Colonel, la, schieß mich, IO. P.Poll. Ähm, hatte gesagt, okay, wir definieren das jetzt mal um. Wir machen das jetzt nicht so, dass du diesen Socket reinschreiben darfst, sobald du nicht mehr blockierst, sondern wenn sozusagen die Bahn nach hinten raus einigermaßen frei ist, wenn sozusagen das, was du mir vorher schon gegeben hast, jetzt schon fast raus ist, also wir geben dir ein bisschen Zeit, ja, dass du jetzt sozusagen, dass du noch ein bisschen Zeit hast, deinen Content zu berechnen oder irgendwie zu erzeugen, den du da rein tun willst. Aber nicht mehr so, wie man es früher machte, dass man seinen Socket vollrotzt, bis der Arzt kommt, also bis man sozusagen blockieren würde. Und er sagt also jetzt, man soll seine Applikation schreiben, dass sie abfragen, wann kann ich in diesen Socket was rein tun und dann sollen sie ihren Content generieren, also zum Beispiel im Beispiel von Screensharing, sollen sie dann eben so ein Frame sich generieren oder einen Snapshot machen, den kompromieren und dann in den Socket rein tun. Das heißt, du bist sozusagen, ich sage jetzt mal ein tolles neues deutsches Wort, real-timiger an deinem Netzwerkstrom. Das heißt, du hast sozusagen besseres Feedback. Weißt du, das ist wie so beim Autofahren, mit einer amerikanischen Auto, mit so dieser Ultraservolenkung spürst du überhaupt nichts von der Straße. Machst irgendwann mal eine Lenkbewegung und vielleicht bewegt sich das Auto auch mal. Das ist so komplett Feedback los. Kann man hier simulieren, man muss nur den Druck aus den Reifen lassen. Er sagt, wir machen jetzt das Fahrwerk ein bisschen straffer. Und die Lenkung auch ein bisschen, dass du sozusagen eher weißt, wann ist das letzte, was ich gesendet habe, wann ist das jetzt raus.
Das ist aber nur interessant für Daten, die gesendet werden, die live sind, also die sozusagen von der Zeit überholt werden. Das geht nicht um Downloads oder BitTorrent oder so, da spielt alles keine Rolle.
Eigentlich nicht, aber dann haben sie das untersucht. Da hat er gesagt, jetzt probieren wir das mal aus, was passiert, wenn wir es jetzt trotzdem einfach so machen, wenn wir jetzt einen Pfeiltransfer oder so was machen, den wir auch in diesem Modus betreiben. Weil er sagt, das tut überhaupt nicht weh. Also so ist es nicht schlechter. Genau, und das ist der Grund, warum sie sagen, das machen sie jetzt in künftigen US-Versionen einfach standardmäßig an, das Feature. So, weil wir festgestellt haben, es gibt einfach keine andere Anwendung mehr, die sinnvoll ist, dass wir uns von denen den Socket vollprügeln lassen. Finde ich, wie gesagt, sehr interessant.
Das haben sie jetzt schon für Screensharing in 10.10.3 schon an. Das heißt, man müsste jetzt eigentlich schon den Effekt spüren, wenn man jetzt auf eine 10.10.3-Maschine Screensharing macht.
Sie baden gerade ihre Hände drin.
Und Available in Linux 2, für die Server-Software, das heißt, auch da scheint, muss ich mal gucken, kann man ja mal nachgucken in den Repositores, Apple scheint da auch zurückzukontributen. Das heißt, wenn die so was basteln, ich hab jetzt auch gerade vor der Sendung nochmal geguckt, dieser Stuart Cheshire, der ist auch regelmäßiger Besucher der ITFs. Ich hab auch fest vorgenommen, dass ich ihm jetzt in Prag mal hingehe und ihm mal ein Bier spendiere und ihm bei der Erlegenheit gleich nochmal ein paar Bugs in seinem IP-Stack noch mal zustecke. Auf dem Blatt Papier oder so. Aber der arbeitet da eben auch mit anderen Leuten zusammen, eben auch mit der Linux-Community oder mit Leuten dort. Das heißt also diese Feature haben sie auch dorthin gespielt, gibt es also auch für Linux-Server. Ansonsten schaut euch die Session an, ihr macht auch eine schöne Demo dazu.
Eine Sache haben wir noch, there's one more thing. Und zwar sprachen sie von TCP Fast Open. Und wenn ich das richtig interpretiert habe, wollen sie die Anzahl der Roundtrips beim Aufbau von TCP-Verbindungen reduzieren. Normalerweise musst du erstmal Hallo, ich will was aufbauen und dann geht irgendwie Daten los und jetzt kann man...
Drei Pakete gehen jetzt.
Quasi, genau. Das heißt, man kann jetzt quasi schon mit dem initialen Paket gleich Daten mit schicken in der Annahme, dass das schon angenommen wird. Und wenn es dann angenommen wird, hat man quasi sein erstes Datenpaket auch schon abgeliefert.
Das heißt, die predikten sozusagen den Success des Öffnen eines Ports und schicken einfach schon los?
Nein, die packen es mit in das SYN-Paket mit rein. Also es ist eine Erweiterung des TCP-Standards. Also jetzt nicht so, dass sie jetzt den normalen TCP-SYN-AG machen, die normale Three-Way Handshake, wie das heißt. Und dann sozusagen schon das nächste TCP-Paket, das Datenpaket gleich hinterherschmeißen, predictively, wie du sagtest. Sondern man hat den Standard dann da angefasst, in ein Syn-Paket, was ja normalerweise nur 40 bytes hat, nämlich 20, IP 20 TCP, da ist ja noch ein bisschen Platz drin, packen sie schon Payload mit rein. Er sagt, hat aber ein Problem, musst du aufpassen. Also das ist gerade für sehr kurzliege TCP-Settings.
Also das ist nicht das, was Google mit dem SSL, also mit diesem HTTPS 2.0 macht, die machen doch da sowas oder nicht?
Ja, die setzen aber auch schon wieder auf TCP, normalem TCP. Das ist ja richtig eine Änderung am TCP-Protokoll. Er sagt, da gibt es natürlich ein Problem damit. Da muss man aufpassen. Das ist gedacht für Transaktionen, die ohnehin wenig Daten zum Beispiel involvieren, wo man sozusagen sagt, nur kleiner Request rein, Antwort raus, Tür zu oder so. Können wir mal schnell eben probieren. So ein bisschen so ein half-hearted UDP-Versuch oder sowas. Das Problem ist, du hast ja in dem Moment, wo du deine Daten nachschickst, noch keine bestätigte Verbindung. Schickst aber schon aktive Daten mit, die auch sozusagen gültig sind für den Empfänger. Und es ist jetzt so, dass es aus verschiedenen Gründen kann sich dieses Sündenpaket, was deine Daten schon trägt, kann ja wiederholt werden, kann ja dupliziert werden im Netz, kann sonst noch was mit passieren. Oder du denkst, das hat nicht geklappt, weil du keine Antwort kriegst, aber der Empfänger hat es schon gesehen. Und da sind ja schon gültige Daten drin. Das heißt, er macht jetzt vielleicht schon was mit deinen Daten. Er sagt, du kannst halt simple Sachen machen, die jetzt keinen State haben oder die dir nicht wehtun. Idem potent, wie es so schön heißt. Kannste machen. Aber wenn du zum Beispiel sagst, schick mal bitte Tim ein Bier oder kauf mal irgendwas für mich, dann kann es durchaus sein, dass du das Ding, was du da gekauft hast, fünfmal kriegst. Deswegen sollst du das für sowas nicht benutzen. Wenn du aber sagst, sag mir mal das Wetter oder sowas, und dann kommt die Frage halt zweimal an beim Server. Dann kriegst du halt zweimal das Wetter. Und dann sagt er, das tut dir nicht weh.
Und diese Erweiterung, wer muss das alles können, wieder auf dem Weg von zwischen Client und Server?
Der Reihenlehrer nach, nur Sender und Empfänger. In Wahrheit natürlich, da hat 5 Milliarden und 30.000 Natt- und Firewall-Devices, die alle glauben, das Protokoll besser verstanden zu haben als du. Die natürlich auch. Weil die denken jetzt gleich, oh, ein TCP-Syn-Paket größer als 40 bytes. Sofort droppen. Ja, aber auch da wieder muss man jetzt sagen, ja, finde ich cool, einer der größten Hersteller sagt, wir machen das, wir bieten das jetzt mal mit an. Die Applikation muss sich selber entscheiden, ob sie das machen will. Und wir werden dann halt innerhalb von kurzer Zeit ein paar 100 Millionen Geräte sehen, die das können und auch ein paar Applikationen, die das gerne haben wollen. Damit erzeugt er halt wieder ein bisschen Druck im Markt. Insgesamt, auch bei den Providern und so zu sagen, hallo, bringt das mal euer Netz in Ordnung.
Da gibt es aber noch kein RFC, weil es noch nicht durch ist oder wie?
Da müsste ich jetzt mal gucken. TCP fast open.
Weil es steht nichts von RFC, es steht nur, es liegt seit 2012 als Entwurf vor. Und der Lineupscanner hat es schon seit Version 3.6 und Server seitlich seit 3.7.
RFC 7.4.1.3, 19. Dezember letzten Jahres. Das ist aber schon ganz gut. Experimental, aber es ist schon RFC-State. Also von daher, es wird schon relativ gut durch. Ich meine, wenn Apple das jetzt in ihr OS einbaut, kommt es aber aus der Google-Ecke, ne? Hast du recht gehabt. Ich denke mal, dass sie das auch haben wollen, damit sie eSpeedy noch ein bisschen Off-Speed kriegen.
Ja, aber ich meine, das beschleunigt ja alles und ist gerade so für diese typischen Webrequest eigentlich ganz sinnvoll, weil im Prinzip jeder Klick erst mal...
Ja, vor allen Dingen, wenn der da reinpasst in das Synth-Paket.
Naja, aber so ein normaler... Weiß nicht, wie groß darf das sein?
Naja, nehmen wir mal so ein normaler... Ethernet MTU sind 1500 Bytes, minus 40 für den IPTCP-Overhead und jetzt ziehen wir nochmal ab, weil es gibt ja PPPI-User draußen, also 1492 minus 40 macht 1452.
Ja, also das reicht ja auf jeden Fall aus.
1452 kann man schon mal ein kleines Liebesbrief reinschreiben.
Da kriegst du die normalen Webklicks mit Cookies rein und ein paar Heller und so. So wie bei Google. Die sind ja auch noch kompressiert. Wenn das auch noch kompressiert ist und so. Das kann richtig was bringen. Vor allem über Netze, die an sich eine sehr niedrige Latenz haben, also wenn du jetzt so ein eieriges Mobilfunknetz hast.
Über Netze, die eine hohe Latenz haben.
Also eine niedrige Responsivität meinte ich.
Es gibt ja immer zwei Parameter, die du hast. Wenn du so einen Netzwerkanschluss hast, der da interessant ist. Du hast jetzt die Bandbreite, sozusagen die rohen Bits pro Sekunde, die da durchgehen und die Latenz, die du hast, sagen wir mal, gemessen zu irgendeinem Hopp. Zum nächsten Hopp deines Providers oder zu irgendeinem Internet Exchange Point. Beispiel Internet über Satellit. Hast du, wenn deine Nachbarn gerade arbeiten sind, hast du superfette Bits da drauf, die du da benutzen kannst. Dummerweise mit einem Delay von 600-700 Millisekunden. Mäh. So, und da macht es natürlich schon Spaß, dass man sozusagen, gerade wenn man diesen dreifach rauen Trip hat, so bei TCP, so Hallo. Ja, hallo. Ja, wirklich hallo. Ja, bis du denn überhaupt erst mal das erste Datenbeit senden kannst, was dann auch noch mal so lange braucht. Ist natürlich schon cool, wenn man sozusagen in seinem ersten Hallo gleich schon noch einen kleinen Liebesbrief mitschicken kann. Finde ich fair.
Ich denke gerade wieder an Wasserhähne. Ich finde immer so ein schönes Beispiel für Latenz und Bandbreite, wenn man sich das irgendwie nicht so richtig klar macht.
Was ist jetzt ein hochlatenter Wasserhahn, einer, den du oben am El Capitan angebracht hast und der dann 1000 Meter runter tropft oder was?
Naja, du kennst ja zum Beispiel diesen Effekt, du willst warmes Wasser haben und dann drehst du halt warm auf und es dauert dann halt sehr lange, bis das gewärmte Wasser auch tatsächlich vorne rauskommt. Das ist sozusagen die Latenz. Naja, und die Bandbreite ist halt einfach wie groß dein Loch ist.
Und der Druck dahinter. Großes Loch alleine reicht nicht.
Ihr macht gerade wieder Vorlagen für David. Da schaut euch das an. Dieser Talk, der hatte auch noch einen Namen, der hieß nämlich Your App and Next Generation Networks. Da ist mal eine Stunde, am Anfang wird diese IPv6-Geschichte nochmal erklärt von einem anderen Mitarbeiter dort von Apple, den ich stimmlich leider so ein bisschen schwererträglich finde, weil er so weil er so jammert spricht, so wie Beaker in einer Muppet Show.
Mal gucken, wie in dir ein Akzent.
Der Akzent ist mir egal, aber der jammert so.
Der jammert? Echt, der jammert? Warte mal, da hör ich mal rein. Der jammert? Der hat einfach nur einen indischen Akzent. Ja, Sekunde.
There's a preflight check, that checks for IPv4 connectivity even before attempting a connection. And that is the reason sometimes you get errors like these.
So in this case, my iPhone was actually connected to the NASX phone network I just created on my Mac device. Es hat nichts mit dem Akzent selber zu tun. Ehrlich nicht, aber das finde ich irgendwie so ein bisschen, sehr anstrengend.
Aber es ist nicht so schlimm, wie französische Konferenzspeaker.
Hör dir mal Deutsche an. Diese World Wide Developers Konferenz ist auch sehr schön, weil du findest ja auch wirklich Spiegel. Gibt jede Menge Deutsche, State of the Union und so. Da ist mal dieser Andreas...
Wendger. W-E-N-D-K-E-R.
Du kennst sie alle. Der macht das auch sehr...
Na, wenn man die Scheiße jahrelang guckt, dann kennt man die irgendwann.
Ja, naja gut, der ist nicht das erste Mal da gewesen.
Und dieser Stora Tschecher, er war ganz bekannt, als halt dieses MDNS eingeführt wurde, da war der auch in aller Munde. Außerdem lese ich seit 20 Jahren Bill Bumgarnas Blog.
Am schwierigsten sind aber trotzdem die Franzosen, finde ich. Also ich meine, ich weiß natürlich nicht, wie schwierig Denglisch für...
Nee, also... Und das liegt ja auch so ein bisschen da dran, dass das so Fremdsprachen da auch nicht so eine hohe Priorität haben. Ich habe mich schon mit einigen französischen Kollegen unterhalten, die ziemlich gut Englisch sprechen und dann so gefragt, wie seht ihr das so? Ist euch das auch schon mal aufgefallen? Und dann meinten die auch so, ja, ist so. Also man muss schon wirklich selber wollen, sonst... Also auch das Niveau von dem Englischunterricht zum Beispiel ist, wo die meinten, die Unterrichts, das kann man jetzt schwer vergleichen, weil die wahrscheinlich nicht an anderen Schulen waren, aber ist schon eher so ein prinzipielles Problem. Und die, die dann halt nicht wirklich selber wollten, die haben dann halt wirklich auch... Also ich sah schon auf diversen Konferenzen, wo ich so...
Franzosen kriege ich noch manchmal runtergeschluckt, aber bei manchen Italienern ist dann wirklich Schluss. Aber wir können ja mal den Rassismus-Blog vielleicht kurz einstellen und noch ein paar gute Nachrichten machen.
Kulturismus ist auch Rassismus. Hat das was mit Rassismus zu tun mit meinen Franzosen?
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen einem Touristen und einem Terroristen?
Haben wir einen Code of Conduct hier eigentlich?
Terroristen haben Sympathisanten. Und unsere stillen Zensurbehörde winken hier die ganze Zeit.
Ich wollte es ja schon mal sagen, ich bin ja für Rollkofferverbot in Berlin mit.
Apropos Verbot in Berlin, kleine Einschreuung. Ja, ist die nicht da? Ist die nicht da, die Struktur? Ich hab das auf der Liste.
Rollkoffer in Berlin hast du in der Liste. Ja, ja, ich weiß jetzt schon, was er sagen will. Berlin. Ich hab extra eine Berlin-Section hier.
Okay, ein Spruch stattgegeben.
Guck hier, Berlin da.
Berlin, Berlin.
Also...
Let's Encrypt.
Let's Encrypt, wir hatten das letzte Mal besprochen. Und jetzt gibt's the breaking news, dass sie einen Zeitplan vorgestellt haben. Also was ist nochmal... Was ist Let's Encrypt? Let's Encrypt ist das Projekt von der IEFF, die Zuteilung von SSL-Zertifikaten hochautomatisiert durchzuführen, sodass wir endlich kostenlos alle mal an Zertifikate rankommen. Und dieses ganze Elend, dass man unglaublich viel Geld ausgeben muss für eine Nulldienstleistung, ein Ende findet.
Ah ja, also da musst du den Satz noch komplett machen natürlich, weil kostenlose Zertifikate gibt's schon jetzt, aber kostenlose Zertifikate, wo das Schlösschen auch zu ist und nicht der Polizist mit dem Schlagstock kommt.
Aber gab's da nicht auch schon von Star TLS?
Nee, die sind nicht umsonst. Ja doch, es gibt so Basteldinger, aber die laufen da bloß einen Monat oder so. Aber was Star TLS macht, ist, du musst halt da nicht für das Zertifikat bezahlen, sondern du zahlst einmal dafür, dass du deine Identität verifizieren und dann kannst du mit deiner verifizierten Identität so viele Zertifikate machen, wie du willst. Sozusagen Zertifikatsflatrate.
Ja, das ist irgendwie alles schon bekloppt. Weil wir wollen ja eigentlich nur Krypto haben und nicht die ganze Zeit immer irgendwas beweisen, wer wir sind.
Manchmal will man beides.
Ja gut, aber man tut es ja hier implizit dadurch, dass man sagt, ich kontrolliere die Domäne und das muss ja irgendwie reichen. So, wie sieht der aus, der Schedule? Der Schedule sieht so aus, dass sie meinen, dass es Mitte September losgeht. General Availability, Week of September 14th, also Mitte September soll es grundsätzlich losgehen. Das erste Zertifikat wollen sie wohl schon am 27. Juli, also in gut einem Monat, raushauen. Was sie da dazwischen machen, weiß ich nicht so ganz genau. Warum dauert es dann nochmal zwei Monate bis zum nächsten Zertifikat? Also wahrscheinlich, wenn sie so mit ausgewählten Teilnehmern in irgendeine Beta-Phase treten und schauen, ob dann irgendwie alles so läuft, wie sie sich das vorstellen. Ja, dann geht's los. Dann kann sogar ich wahrscheinlich hier nicht mehr mich entziehen.
Kannst du auch schon vorher nicht.
Doch, siehst du ja.
Aber ich muss ja sagen, letztendlich, also ich würde ja immer noch persönlich lieber haben, wenn ich meine eigene CA sein könnte und auch kein Polizist mit Schlagstock käme.
Du kannst ja deine eigene CA sein.
Aber nicht ohne Schlagstock.
Das Problem ist nur...
Wobei, das haben sie den Chef, der hat nicht mehr so einen großen Schlagstock.
Da ist theoretisch eigentlich auch nichts dagegen. Das einzige Problem, das die meisten Leute damit haben, ist, wie können sie dir vertrauen, dass du jetzt nicht Zertifikate rausgibst für www.google.com oder gmail.com oder imap.gmx.net? Das ist das ganze Problem. Es gibt übrigens in X509 Provisions dafür, dass man Zertifikate ausstellen kann mit sogenannten Constraints. Das heißt, eine CA kann dir theoretisch eine CA geben, wo du nur Zertifikate ausstellen kannst, die aufs myk.net oder so was enden oder so was. Ist auch sehr lustig, ist drin in den Standards, man kann das auch machen, OpenSSL kann das auch, aber wenn du jetzt mal guckst, welche Browser oder welche SSL-Libraries das auch wirklich beachten, diese Constraints, stellst du leider fest, dass da so noch ein bisschen Opul bedarf herrscht.
Ich finde ja bei so vielen im Internet und so, finde ich ja so dieses Delegationsprinzip, also gerade so bei DNS und so, ich finde das ja total charmant und so, ne? Und irgendwie bei diesen CA's und diesen Zertifikaten, da fühle ich mich irgendwie die ganze Zeit irgendwie so wie, warum ist das eigentlich da so bescheuert?
Weil das halt nur halb implementiert ist. Wenn alle diese Leute, die alle Library's, diese Constraints ordentlich beachten würden, könnte man das machen. Dann haben allerdings natürlich die kommerziellen CA's ihr Business-Modell, sie sehen so ein bisschen davon schwimmen. Allerdings ist das jetzt ohnehin schon da, weil es gibt ja schon seit einiger Zeit diese sogenannten Wildcard-Domains. Das heißt, du kannst dir ja Sternpunktsmögen nicht holen und dann hast du deine Delegation. Naja, mehr oder weniger.
Ist halt alles so meh.
Na gut, die andere Alternative ist, das komplett über DNS laufen zu lassen, aber das kommt ja auch nicht so richtig in die Puschen. Na, also ich hab mir, ich weiß nicht, ich hatte mir da letzte Woche schon drüber gesprochen, das ist jetzt irgendwie noch nicht so lange her, dass ich weiß, ich glaube, ich hab mir erst nach dem, nach der Sendung angeschaut.
Du redest davon, dass man Self-Sign-Certificates reinmacht, und sozusagen die Verankerung in der großen, weiten Welt, in dem Netz, nicht dadurch macht, dass du dir von irgendeiner CA unterschreiben lässt, sondern dass du das ins DNS reinmachst.
Genau. Und ich hab mir nämlich den Vortrag angeschaut, zu Let's Encrypt, der auf dem 31C3 lief, den hatte ich irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, der ist mir irgendwie durch die Lappen gegangen. Und kann ich auch allen, die das Thema interessierten, die ihn noch nicht gesehen haben, nochmal empfehlen. Der ist auch sehr kompakt, der eigentliche Vortrag dauert nur eine halbe Stunde. Sehr interessant ist aber die Fragerunde danach. Also auf dem Kongress, muss ich sagen, werden ja echt gute Nachfragen gestellt.
Also das war wirklich so.
Da kam dann halt auch dieser Aspekt und meinte, naja, es wäre halt gerade nicht so ihr Fokus. Jetzt Dane und so weiter, weil sie wollen ja explizit das andere Problem erstmal lösen. Beobachten das da aber und sehen durchaus auch noch, wenn ich das jetzt richtig erinnere, da haben Möglichkeiten, dass man zum Beispiel auch über das DNS zumindest auch nochmal bestätigt, dass das sozusagen, das ließe sich ja auch kombinieren.
Ja, machst du sozusagen eine Signatur von deinem Zertifikat, die hinterlegst du sozusagen im DNS.
Genau. Ich habe nicht nur ein gültiges Zertifikat, sondern mein DNS sagt auch genau dieses Zertifikat und kein anderes.
Was auch gut dafür ist, dass ja nicht die nordkoreanische Staats-CA ein Zertifikat für deine Domäne ausstellen kann sein.
Genau, weil man kann ja da so man in the middle mäßig einfach da in den SSL-Strom reingehen und irgendein Zertifikat präsentieren. Also hier, keine Ahnung, bei den Chinesen ist das ja schon durchaus mal vorgekommen, da auch mit Apple, dass die da schon so auch ja hier apple.com und so haben wir, weil sie sich halt selber da ein Zertifikat für ausstellen können und die Brauser eben diese fälschenden CAs akzeptieren. Das ist ja im Prinzip ein extrem großes Loch.
Das ist aber die Benutzung von DNS auch nicht richtig fälschungssicher, wenn man nicht sowas wie DNSSEC deploitert. DNSSEC ist ja zwar ein durchaus interessanter Mechanismus, ich habe die ja auf meinen Domains auch schon seit längerem drauf, aber es gab ja letztlich auch mal ein bisschen Kritik daran, die auch nicht ganz von der Hand weisen kann, weil es halt eben, es gibt einen politischen Gap dazwischen. Als die Leute das erfunden haben, waren wir kryptografisch auf dem anderen Stand, das war noch weit vor Snowden und so weiter und so fort, d.h. man hat damals gedacht, ach wir nehmen hier unten eine dode kleine Krypto, passt schon, wird schon keiner kranken können und so. Und noch so ein paar andere kleine Flaws und dann hat man DNSSEC erfunden und alle wählte erst mal so, ja erfindet ihr mal, interessiert uns nicht. Und jetzt wurde plötzlich spannend, es wird sozusagen dieser eigentlich, sagen wir mal, nicht in seiner Intention und an den meisten Implementationen veralteter Standard sozusagen wieder vorgekramt. Jetzt kommen natürlich die Leute sagen, ja die Krypto, die da drin ist, ist aber weak. Also was man jetzt bräuchte, wer jetzt, wo der heiß, wo der Scheiß noch heiß ist, müsste jetzt die ITF hingehen und sagen, jetzt machen wir noch mal ein bisschen, bohren wir das nochmal auf, definieren nochmal aktuelle Krypto-Standards darauf, verbreiten aktuelle Libraries dafür und so. Das ist jetzt sozusagen der Schritt, der da noch fehlt. Weil vorher kannst du ins DNS reinschreiben, was du willst. Das macht der Attacker, der deinen SSL-Stream aufmacht und da irgendwelche komischen Zertifikate reinlügt, noch viel einfacher auf als dein SSL. Also bevor das DNS nicht gesichert ist.
Genau und es gibt ja hier auch, hatte ich dir auch mal geschickt den Link, als wir uns mal so unterhalten haben. Da gibt es nämlich einen ganz coolen Blogpost. Den kannst du dir auch mal reinfahren, Timme. Hier, wo ist denn mein Chat?
Der ist natürlich auch ein Extremist.
Ja genau, das muss man auch so mit einem Teelöffelchen Salz vielleicht sich reinfahren, aber es ist ja immer mal ganz gut, so die beiden immer so die Enten vom Spektrum sich reinzufahren, weil irgendwo dazwischen liegt dann halt die Wahrheit. Und so ein paar Punkte sind da schon ganz drin, weil so oft ist ja so, hat man immer dieses Confirmation-Bias, wenn man irgendwie auch schon selber an so eine Sache glaubt, dann liest man auch immer nur die Blogpost und hört sich die Sachen besonders gerne an, die seine eigene Meinung bestätigen. Und dann gibt's halt doch mal ab und zu wieder irgendwie so einen Artikel, der einem so komplett von der anderen Seite die Kugel anstupst.
Der ist schon ein bisschen ärgerlich, weil er hat nicht Unrecht komplett, aber er hat auch extreme Positionen. Er sagt zum Beispiel, das fängt ja damit an, das braucht keine Sau. Das sehe ich nicht so. Ich finde, dass man das gerne haben möchte und das gibt auch gute Gründe dafür. Und dann solche Sprüche wie, ja, das ist aber government controlled, ja, das ist das ganze Scheiß DNS. Es geht ja nur darum, Daten zu sichern, die da drin stehen. Wenn jetzt die Bundesregierung die Kontrolle über denig übernimmt und jetzt plötzlich nach Gutdünken in der DE-Zone rumfuhr wirkt, ja, dann hast du aber auch nix, was du da absichern willst. Deswegen ist es an dieser Stelle egal. Also das ist nicht ganz, aber trotzdem. Das ist so ein Punkt, da muss man halt drüber diskutieren. Aber es ist trotzdem ein interessantes Ding zu lesen. Obwohl es einen ärgert. Ich bin ja selber Extremist.
Die Bundesregierung auf einmal Denik kontrolliert.
Die verstehen ja glücklicherweise nicht.
Das ist ja alles Neuland. Die haben das Denik neujahr nicht gefunden.
Deren Datenautobahn hat nur Kopfsteinpflaster.
Wer ist denn dieser MrSockPopIt Org hier? Oder ist das eine Frau?
Sind sogar Frau und Mann, guck an. Damit hast du nicht errechnet.
Erin klingt jetzt nicht, weiß ich nicht.
Doch, Erin ist doch bestimmt ein super toller irischer Frauenname.
Die Tor-Developerin heißt doch Erin.
Zum Beispiel.
Egal, wie auch immer, ist unklar und auch unwichtig. Irgendein Geschlecht wird sicherlich auf irgendeiner Art vorliegen bei denen.
Tim ist heute total diplomatisch im politischen Korrektheit.
Gerade in der Krise.
Gewollt, aber nicht gekr...
Bleiben wir doch bei Security.
Schmickurity.
Genau. Und mit einem Blick auf den Mac im Besonderen. Da wurde gerade eben vor kurzem gestern, ich weiß nicht...
Heute habe ich es gelesen.
Ja.
Also gelesen, aber nicht ganz, weil ich musste arbeiten.
Genau. Ich habe noch nicht so ganz verstanden, was da Sache ist. Aber es gibt hier wohl irgendwie böse Zero Days, werden hier irgendwie angekündigt und so. Keine Sicherheitslücke ohne fancy name heutzutage.
Werner, Karl-Heinz, das sind doch meine Namen. Warum heißen die immer so exotisch?
Na, wie würdest du denn eine von dir entdeckte Sicherheitslücke nennen?
Karl-Heinz.
Karl-Heinz. Karl-Heinz macht dich fettisch.
Werner. Klaus Peter, wenn dann bitte.
Klaus Peter macht dich fettisch.
Ja, aber...
Fängt dir schon wieder damit an.
Seine Bugs? Warum heißt dein Bug nicht Petra?
Na, weil das negativ ist und die Männer sowieso alle Schweine sind und alles kaputt machen.
Wenn du lauten Schreikrampflos werden willst, will ich erst unmuteen.
Wie auch immer. Was macht dieses Xara? Ich hab's nur so, ich weiß nicht.
Du hast doch voll super erklärt. Wer war das von euch beiden? Ich war das.
Das war doch super.
Ich hab's super erklärt, aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass ich es verstanden habe. Also das, was ich glaubte, verstanden zu haben, das kann ich total super erklären. Das kann ich ja auch nochmal machen. Also wenn ich das richtig sehe, also diese Demo, die sie hier zeigen, auf die Keychain von OS X, ist, dass sie quasi mit einer App in der Keychain ein Key anlegen und den so nennen, wie ihn auch andere Systeme nennen würden. Zum Beispiel andere Apps oder Systemkomponenten. Genau, in dem Beispiel ist es ja die iCloud-Control-Pane bzw. dieses ganze Internet-Accounts-Dingsbums. Und wenn ich mich da halt in meine iCloud einlogge und das Passwort eingebe, dann wird das ja in der Keychain abgelegt unter einem besonderen Namen. Und der Trick hier scheint mir zu sein, dass eine App halt dem einfach zuvorkommt. Das heißt, sie legt diesen Eintrag mit diesem Namen, der nicht geschützt ist, schon mal an und trägt sich selber damit auch als zugriffsberechtigt ein. Und wenn dann halt die iCloud-Control-Pane kommt und man das Passwort eingibt, dann versucht iCloud oder diese Control-Pane, diesen Key anzulegen, den es aber schon gibt. Und anstatt einen komplett neuen Eintrag zu erzeugen, mercht das quasi mit dem bereits existierenden Eintrag. Sodass zwar das richtige Passwort da reingeschrieben wird, aber dabei halt nicht diese Zugriffsberechtigung für diese böse App.
Sie hat es alle nicht, sie darf da noch an.
Genau, die darf da noch an.
Das heißt, das geht aber nur für Sachen, die da nachkommen. Das klang aber so, dass die halt eben auch Sachen wegfischen, die schon auf meinem Rechner drauf sind.
Das entzieht sich jetzt sozusagen meiner Kenntnis. Aber das ist das, was ich jetzt dieser Demo entnommen habe. Ich habe das jetzt eine Stunde vor der Sendung irgendwie mir reingepfiffen. Und ich bin ja auch nicht wirklich bekannt dafür, dass ich jetzt hier immer alles bis ins letzte Detail verstehe und erklären kann. Das muss jetzt erst mal reichen soweit.
Bei Kalendern schon, alles andere? Das versteht sich von selbst.
Haben wir uns eigentlich schon über Adressbuchserver unterhalten?
Übrigens weiß ich gar nicht, ob ich das letzte Mal erzählt habe, weil es passt jetzt schön hier mit der Sicherheit. Kaspersky hat ja auch irgendwie so eine fette Attacke auf sein eigenes Netzwerk erfahren. Und im Wire, in der aufwired.com, gab es einen sehr ausführlichen Artikel dazu, wo sie so, also sie haben das halt detectiert und auch noch mal geguckt, wie sie da sich durch die ganzen Systeme gebohrt haben. Und den Artikel mal zu lesen desillusioniert auch noch den letzten wahrscheinlich, der daran glaubt, dass man irgendwie den Computer am Internet wirklich so ganz sicher machen kann. Ja genau, oder T-Systems-Beauftragenden. Klappt das schon. Aber liest euch das mal durch. Der ist wirklich ziemlich lang, aber das ist total abgefahren, wie da durch die Systeme durchgebohrt wurde. Ich hab dir den Link da schon reingetan. Das war...
Management Summary?
Ja, Management Summary ist nichts ist sicher. Wenn jemand euch wirklich dran kriegen will, dann schafft er das auch. Und dieser Artikel...
Kasperski hat schon ganz schön Balls of Steel, dass sie hingehen und freimütig zugeben, dass man bei ihnen im Netz rumgehackt hat. Und dass sie da eben ein ordentliches Tier gefunden hat.
Also der ganze Artikel ist echt lesenswert. Der ist ziemlich lang, aber den kann man schön morgens bei einer Tasse Kaffee oder so.
Was ich jetzt neulich gelesen habe, so dein neuer heißer Scheiß bei Malware, es gibt ja schon so normale Malware, die sich dann einnissen. Dann haben sie gesagt, wir nisten uns jetzt ein bisschen in dein Betriebssystem ein, als Treiber und so, das ist auch schön. Dann gab es irgendwelche Leute, die gesagt haben, wir machen jetzt mal, Dios ist ja beschreibbar von deinem PC, wir malen uns mal da rein, das ist auch schon wieder kalt, der neue heiße Scheiß ist. Die patchen sich in die Firmware von deiner Platte rein. Das heißt, wenn du deine Platte nicht auswechselst, kriegst du es auch nicht wieder runter. Also die ganzen Patch-Mechanismen für die Plattenfirmware gleich mit disablen. Das heißt, wenn du deine Platte nicht ausbaust und wegschmeißt, nützt dir auch die Reinstallation deines Systems nicht mehr. Find ich gut.
Deswegen muss der Bundestag sich ja jetzt auch neu machen.
Hier steht ja irgendwie ganz witzig, außerdem ist es ja logisch, die vielen Daten in der Wolke müssen irgendwann und irgendwo wieder abregnen. Da gab es so einen Spruch vom CCC auch hier, wie wir das, Informationen wollen frei sein. Das ist auch so eine, finde ich, eine sehr schöne, grundsätzliche Wahrheit, dass irgendwie, wo die Informationen anfallen, irgendwann vaporieren die auf die eine oder andere Weise, gewollt oder ungewollt, wieder raus.
Wenn wir schon gerade bei den Hacks sind, dann müssten wir aber auch kurz noch mal reden, dass auch die Bude, die Last Pass macht, wurde auch gehackt. Das ist so ein, ja, da werden die Passwörter nicht bei dir lokal gespeichert, sondern bei deren irgendwie Cloud oder jedenfalls externe Server. Und da gibt es ja auch Leute, die das benutzen, weil es kostet wohl nichts. Und die wurden wohl auch gehackt. Die sagen, die richtigen Passwörter sind nicht raus, aber die verschlüsselte Version davon ist raus und so weiter und so fort. Also das ist eigentlich wohl doch sicher, aber sicherheitshalber sollte man sein Passwort wechseln. Ich kann damit nur sagen, man sollte keinen Passwortdienst benutzen, wo die Passwörter nicht bei einem liegen, sondern woanders. Das ist meine Meinung.
Ich kannte den auch gar nicht. Last Pass.
Last Pass, du auch, ist ziemlich bekannt.
Last Pass, P-A-S-S.
Genau, wie Password.
In dem Fall hat Dennis nicht das TH falsch ausgesprochen.
Habe ich es mal hinbekommen?
Nee, also Doppel S war ja richtig.
Ach so, deswegen.
Ich bin da irgendwie davon ausgegangen.
Wie viel noch eine Gruppe ein, die man schwer findet, aber wollte nicht sagen, wegen meinem TH, aber... Kannst du noch erinnern damals? Die findest du nie im Internet.
Meinen die das ernst? Man speichert Passwörter online?
Was kann da schon schief gehen, Tim?
Keychain in the Cloud ist doch der gleiche Scheiß. Also so gesehen ist ja jetzt nichts Neues, ne?
Selbe Scheiß ist aber auch One Password mit Dropbox-Synchronisation.
Ja, das auch. Sollte man auch nicht machen.
Also keine Ahnung, was bei denen da falsch gelaufen ist.
Unsere Zensoren wedelt hier mit den Armen, aber es ist mir nicht klar, was du jetzt damit sagen willst.
Es ist ja leider auch nicht sprachberechtigt, deswegen...
Oder willst du was sagen?
Da ist die Taste, da.
So, dann muss Tim auch noch einen Track anlegen oder so, oder bist du da total...
Nee, warte mal.
Jetzt kann man mich hören, okay. Ja, das muss ich mir wahrscheinlich auch noch vorstellen. Ich bin die anonyme...
Du bist die anonyme Zensurin.
Also ich dürfte sogar was sagen grundsätzlich. Also so ist es nicht. Zu dem Last Pass habe ich tatsächlich jetzt... Die letzte Folge Security Now! Ist da ein guter Einstieg, was sie da gemacht haben, beziehungsweise was da passiert ist, und dass die eigentlich relativ gut reagiert haben darauf. Ich kann es leider nicht mehr so in Einzelheiten wiedergeben, aber man ist da weniger skeptisch, als das jetzt hier in der Runde ist, was den...
Ja, habe ich auch gelesen, auch dass die Passwort-Algorithmen, oder das, so wie sie sich da verschließen, mit irgendwie 100.000 Runden, ist es etwas mehr als irgendwie Standard, oder wie auch immer. Aber am Ende ist der Fakt, sie haben verkackt. Und zweitens...
Es reimt sich, sag das nochmal.
Zweitens sind da meine Passwörter bei denen. Das heißt, das darf gar nicht passieren. Also ich finde, da ist schon der Fehler.
Bei zweiterem gebe ich dir Recht, dass die Passwörter da sind. Das ist nicht das, wie man das haben will. Sie haben verkackt. Da wäre ich ein bisschen vorsichtig, weil sie haben tatsächlich die Warnung rausgegeben, als sie während der Standardbeobachtung gesehen haben, dass möglicherweise ein komischer Datenstrom passiert ist. Und dann haben sie schon irgendwie gesagt, Leute, wäre es möglich, dass irgendwie die verschlüsselten, noch nicht nochmal 100.000 Mal verschlüsselten, gehashten Passwörter möglicherweise komprimitiert sind. Und ihr solltet sie bitte ändern. Und haben sich damit erst mal selber abgeschossen. Das war ein bisschen ungünstig.
Von der Last Year meinst du von denen?
Also Security Now, die Folge dazu.
Aber ich werde auch immer noch so ein bisschen skeptisch, was mir eine Firma sagt, was der Umfang von dem Hack ist, den sie erleiden mussten. Also, da weiß ich nicht, ob man ihnen auch immer so trauen kann. Und am Ende sind es halt meine Daten und da bin ich halt ein bisschen eigen. Also ich würde es eh nicht benutzen, davon abgesehen, aber auch wenn ich es benutzen würde und die erzählen mir, ja wir wurden ja gehabt, aber ja geht schon, es ist jetzt nicht ganz so schlimm, dann wäre ich trotzdem noch ein bisschen skeptisch.
Du bist gebranntes Kind hier von, wie heißen sie, diese Bitcoin-Börse, die...
Zum Beispiel.
Ja, aber also ich meine, letztendlich würde ich halt, ich als alter Cloud-Skeptiker würde halt auch sagen, machst du dir auch so einen Chance.
So ja, nun nicht, sagst du. Ja, so oder so müssen wir jetzt natürlich unsere neue Teilnehmerin vorstellen. Jetzt hast du dich, jetzt bist du dran.
Jetzt hab ich was gesagt.
Ich dachte, du willst nur hier zu Gast rum, und das Beste ist, ne, ne, ne, Tim, warte, warte.
Also die Hörer, die sind jetzt total geschockt, anyway. Und noch geschockter.
Hier wird schon gefragt, ob ihr Vibes anwesend seid.
Und noch geschockter werden sie sein, wenn ich jetzt sage, dass die Anonyme Zensoren eigentlich die ganze Zeit hier bei jeder einzelnen Folge gesessen hat. Schon immer.
Und jetzt ist einfach ihr Beißholz durchgesessen.
Sie saß hier jetzt heute in dieser Folge und hat es wirklich nicht mehr auf dem Stuhl ausgehalten. Sie hat jetzt nicht das Mikro mit einer sehr kräftigen Geste vor das Gesicht gezogen.
Was man ja immer nicht sieht, ich wedel hier eigentlich immer mit Fähnchen in verschiedenen Farben, je nachdem, ob das jetzt irgendwie in die falsche Richtung ist. Lustig war oder nicht.
Lustig, genau. Und ein paar Schalbkärtchen. Wie heißen diese Schobikärtchen?
Und letzte Woche hatte sie Urlaub, aber...
So oder so, wir begrüßen Annalena. Hallo Annalena, willkommen in der Freak Show. Später Einstieg, aber später die Gäste, desto... So sieht es aus.
Frisch eingeflohen. Ich hab mich heimlich rausgeschlichen, sie reingelassen vorhin.
Genau. Können wir irgendwas über dich erzählen?
Ja, ich kann was über mich sagen.
Mach mal.
Ja, Annalena, warum darf ich hier in dieser illustren Runde überhaupt irgendwie... Das fragen wir uns auch. Zensur halt. Ja, Zensur. Die Zensurin arbeitet bei der Bahn und hat im weitesten Sinne was mit WLAN und Zügen zu tun. Deswegen habe ich auch eben...
Dabei ist es noch nicht mal erwähnt. Ich habe gerade erst vor ein paar Folgen erklärt, dass es nicht euer WLAN ist.
Deswegen habe ich hier eben auch schon bei den WBDC-Ankündigungen zu TCP und ECN doch etwas erstaunt geguckt, weil ich das noch nicht gehört hatte und ja, ich muss fortgehen.
Könnte an deinem Dienstleister liegen.
Das war ein spannendes Thema, auch für WLAN-Aufzüge, im Besonderen wahrscheinlich.
Kann man da ein Thema draus machen oder? Wir könnten das machen. Ich weiß rein zufällig, dass Anna-Lena sich auch schlau gemacht hat, wie das im Ausland funktioniert.
Also grundsätzlich, sagen wir mal so, das ist immer so eine Sache, ob ich Dinge erzählen. Solange ich nicht zu nah an spezielle Verbindungen in der Deutschen Bahn rankomme, kann ich durchaus allgemein, also ich spreng euch jetzt gerade euren schönen Das passt sehr gut in Security rein.
Wo arbeitest du dann im Hauptbahnhof?
Ich arbeite in Frankfurt. Ja genau, beim Fernwärts.
Die arbeiten im Hauptbahnhof.
Ja, aber grundsätzlich arbeiten auch welche. Da sitzen auch ganz viele. Das ist aber ein anderer Teil.
Ich dachte, die sitzen irgendwo draußen in Lichtenberg.
Die sitzen überall, die sind überall. Alles ist durchzogen.
Okay, ohne jetzt den Eindruck machen zu wollen, dass wir, ohne jetzt irgendwas hier ins Lächerliche zu ziehen, also du bist eine der Personen, die versucht, das wissen wir, die Situation nachhaltig zu verbessern. Ja, das ist so und wir tun, was wir können, um das zu unterstützen, auch schon länger. Und vielleicht können wir ja mal, das fände ich jetzt mal interessant, dass du vielleicht einfach mal kurz, hast du mal eine Stunde Zeit? Nee, dass man einfach mal kurz sagt, was eigentlich so die Realität ist gerade. Also nicht, was überhaupt irgendwie jetzt auch offiziell irgendwie geplant ist zu tun oder was vielleicht überhaupt die ist-Situation ist. Und ich meinte gerade, du hast dich auch mit den anderen europäischen Nationen beschäftigt.
Stimmt das? Also ich meine, natürlich. Also WLAN auf Zügen funktioniert bei uns, genau wie im europäischen Ausland, eigentlich immer gleich. Also da ist irgendwie keine…
Stimmt nicht. In Schweden funktioniert es nämlich.
Also wenn wir jetzt die ganze Zeit an der Stelle rumkriechen wollen, dann werde ich hier viel Spaß haben in der Sendung. Ich kann natürlich zu bestimmten Themen einfach nichts sagen und an der Stelle, zum Beispiel wie ist jetzt der Plan und wie geht es denn weiter und so, da kann ich tatsächlich gerade keine Aussagen zu machen. Ich meine grundsätzlich, deswegen komme ich jetzt auch von dieser TCP-Geschichte wieder zurück. Es funktioniert ja immer gleich. Es gibt einen großen Router auf einem Zug, der ist irgendwo in der Mitte, verteilt dann über den Backbone die Signale im Zug an Access Points, an denen sich dann die Endgeräte einloggen. Der Router ist gleichzeitig DHCP wie zu Hause. Dann wird das Ganze halt über Mobilfunk abgeführt. Vom Router über ein oder mehrere Provider, je nachdem, wird an einem zentralen Gateway wieder zusammengesetzt und geht ins Internet. So funktioniert das mit den Zügen.
Und wofin hängt das ab? Ich meine, wir hatten ja jetzt in den letzten zwei Jahren, kam ja immer mal wieder eine Strecke dazu. Das könnte man ja sagen. Warum funktioniert das nicht sowieso an allen Strecken?
Weil die doofen Mobilfunker ihre Türmchen da hinbauen, wo man ihr Netz nicht benutzen darf, nämlich im Auto. Deswegen haben die doofen Mobilfunker erst mal die Autobahnen vollgeklastet mit ihrem Dreck. Und da, wo man das Netz benutzen dürfte, nämlich während man schön in der Bahn sitzt, sind sie noch so ein bisschen...
Ja, aber das ist tatsächlich sehr gut zusammengefasst. Also das war tatsächlich auch die Situation. Ich meine, das ist auch irgendwie kein Geheimnis.
Ja, aber das heißt, diese Strecken waren tatsächlich deshalb nicht...
Es gab gar nichts.
Es gab aber deshalb nichts, weil da einfach keine Türme in der Nähe von Bahnstrecken waren. Exakt.
Also die Situation Ende 2005, Anfang 2006, da war kein GSM, da war nichts.
Also na gut, aber es gibt doch dieses Bahn-GSM, das dürfte ja wohl schon da gewesen sein.
Das ist ja was anderes.
Ja, okay, aber sozusagen diese ganzen schnellere Netze. Und womit hat man angefangen, also als das erste Bahn-GSM?
Nein, es gab gar nichts. Also es gab wirklich auch keine Telefonie, es gab gar nichts. Und das ist halt so ein Punkt, ja jetzt muss ich mal kurz, jetzt bin ich schon wieder in schwierigen Fahrversammeln wahrscheinlich. Aber nein, das ist noch gar nicht mal so. Also es ist tatsächlich so, dass das, sagen wir mal so, die Netze, wer da jetzt ist, ist halt auf jeden Fall die Deutsche Telekom an den Strecken. Und der Rest zieht so allmählich nach. Die anderen, also Vodafone und Autos.
Das heißt, alle Mobilfunk-Provider sind dabei.
Die müssen noch nachholen, aber die sind...
Auch an den Bahnstrecken präsenter zu werden.
Fernverkehrsstrecken, ja.
Und das haben die jetzt auch mittlerweile verstanden, dass man im Zug auch Zeit hat zu telefonieren und im Auto nicht? Das ist ja irgendwie bemerkenswert, dass das so lange gedauert hat.
Und das ist halt jetzt in Deutschland auch noch irgendwie von der Topographie her ein bisschen schwieriger, als das in einigen, also schwieriger in einigen anderen Ländern ist. Also man muss halt zum Teil sehr viel mehr Türme auch hinstellen. Da hat man es im flachen Land ein bisschen einfacher. Aber ja, das ist tatsächlich so, da ist noch ein bisschen was zu tun. Aber da sind ja jetzt auch die Mobilfunk-Frequenzvergaben an der Stelle auch in der Richtung unterwegs, dass man zumindest die Fernverkehrsstrecken bei den Neuvergaben auf dem 700er-Frequenzband dann jetzt auch mal ausleuchten muss. Also derjenige, der sich das 700-Megahertz-Frequenzband krallt, der muss dann auch mal ran und ran an die Bahn.
Das ist diese digitale Dividende-Abteilung?
Genau.
Das heißt, da kriegt die Bahn dann auch was von ab?
Da kriegt die Bahn dann auch was von ab, ja.
Soll ich sagen, die Bahnstrecke konkret. Weil es sind ja Türmchen, die draußen stehen. Das heißt, also auch alles, was nicht Bahn AG ist, aber auf dem Gleis fährt, kriegt das dann ab.
Dresinen und so.
Oder daneben wohnt oder so. Oder genau.
Es ist mir schon bewusst, dass das nicht nur am Gleis entlangfließt.
So, die machen das dann aber auch gleich on air. Ist klar.
Aber weißt du, machen denn auch alle Bahnunternehmen in Europa dasselbe Partnership mit den Telekom-Unternehmen? Oder machen die anderen mehr oder noch weniger, um irgendwie Internet im Zug bereitzustellen?
Also sagen wir, dass dieses exklusive Partner-Modell, das ist meines Wissens nach in Europa einmalig. Also die anderen machen das anders. Also da gibt es dann, die sind immer auch sehr viel später gekommen, muss man vielleicht noch mal dazusagen. Wer ist später gekommen? Also die Deutsche Bahn war die zweite Bahn in Europa. Mit Internet? Mit Internet, Hochgeschwindigkeitsflotte, ja. Ernsthaft?
Was war die erste?
Drei Monate hinter den Schweden. Es gab vorher keine, ja, das ist tatsächlich so. Das kannst du nachgucken.
Auch Thales nicht? Ich hatte den Eindruck, dass Thales schon vorher Internet hatte.
Aber jetzt nur in Europa, was ist denn so mit den Japanern und so?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Finkantz fährt ja schon länger rum mit irgendwelchen Dokumos.
Also wie gesagt, wir haben Anfang 2006 angefangen. Moment, die Deutsche Bahn hat 2006 angefangen. Anfang 2006, genau. Da wurden dann die ersten Züge mit...
Ist noch...
Also ich meine, was andere natürlich zum Teil... Also andere und ich möchte... Okay, spart mir Anschlussfragen, ja. Andere machen... Schweden, Schweden, nehmen wir doch mal ein Akademienbeispiel. Schweden ist toll, weil die haben da tatsächlich ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr cooles System an Wort, dass tatsächlich auch irgendwie alle... Fünf Mobilfunk-Provider, vier?
Wobei die Schweden noch ein Special haben, dann gibt es noch sozusagen Netze, die gebildet werden aus den anderen normalen Providen. Es gibt sozusagen nur vier Leute, die dir SIM-Karten verkaufen, aber vom Prinzip sechs Netze. Sechs technische Netze.
Ich meine, sie würden fünf nutzen, wie auch immer. Also ich habe jetzt die Zahl fünf im Kopf.
Also auf jeden Fall nicht nur einen.
Nicht nur einen und haben dann auch sehr intelligentes Management dann auf diesem, ich nenne es jetzt mal Router, weil das so der allgemeine Begriff ist, dass dann in der Lage ist, diese verschiedenen Netze und auch die verschiedenen Technologien an der Stelle intelligent so zu verbinden, dass halt immer echt gut Bandbreite da ist. Das ist schon toll. Also das in Schweden, ich kann verstehen, warum man das gut findet. Also ich habe da selber schon drin gesessen und habe mal auch mal gemessen, was die da so machen. Und das ist schon schön, schon beeindruckend. Und jetzt?
Was sind jetzt die großen Herausforderungen?
Keine Folgefragen, hast du gesagt.
Das war eine neue Frage.
Pressemeldungen sind uns ja alle bekannt. Das heißt, wir arbeiten hart.
Und jetzt gibt es nicht nur zweispurige Daten, Autobahnen, sondern auch zweispurige Hochgeschwindigkeits-ICE-Internet-Strecken.
Was ich immer wieder faszinierend finde, weil du gerade Pressemeldung sagtest, ist, ihr werdet ja auch so ein bisschen geprügelt von der Politik, obwohl jetzt sozusagen eigentlich ja gar nicht deren Aufgabe ist. Es gibt ja gewisse Minister, die immer aufstehen und sagen, so machen wir das jetzt. Und ich frage mich immer, hallo, seit wann arbeitest du denn auf bei der Bahn? Beziehungsweise, seit wann arbeitest du denn bei Dollar Provider, der das für die Bahn macht? Aber der ist immer sehr großspurig da drin, weil er so verkündet. Ist das so, weil er sich das ausdenkt oder weil der Bahnvorstand ihn das ins Ohr flüstert oder wo kommt das immer her?
Jetzt müssen wir ganz kurz, ich sitze ja jetzt hier nicht als als Vertreterin der Deutschen Bahn, deswegen kann ich dazu, ja, ich kann natürlich sagen, gut, klar, Herr Dobrindt ist da schon gut vorweg. Das ist natürlich für einen, also das kann man sich glaube ich auch vorstellen, wenn man so ein bisschen weiß, dass die Deutsche Bahn ja ein Staatskonzern ist, obwohl er eine Aktiengesellschaft ist und auch die Untergruppen Aktiengesellschaften sind, der aber zu 100 Prozent im Bund gehört und na klar. Also da haben die auch Einfluss. Da haben die ihn möglicherweise. Ich kann da erkennten, possibly comment.
Naja, das machen sie halt, weil...
Wenn man da hingeht, sagt, hallo, hier sind Teile der Infrastruktur kaputt, könnte man dafür sorgen, dass alle privat sind.
Naja, das kennen wir doch nur in das Spiel.
Davon wird man nicht besonders überrascht.
Was war denn dein erster Computer?
Die wichtige Frage hier für alle Gäste. Mein eigener erster.
Hattest du schon mal einen?
Ich sitze hier mit Notizblock und Stift.
Ja, ich sitze tatsächlich hier mit Notizblock und Stift.
Und zwei Phones.
Und zwei Phones, ja. Eins davon hasse ich, das andere ist das, was ich benutze. Das erste Mal, dass ich an einem Computer sitzen durfte, war glaube ich ein 686er von meinem Date. Da war noch ein Windows 2 Punkt. Was war das dann? 586er? Wo man dann noch Win eingeben musste, damit das Windows startete.
Das war aber älter als 686er.
486er.
Von welchem Jahr reden wir denn jetzt?
Dass ich zum ersten Mal an einem Rechner gesessen habe.
Anfang der 90er.
Ende 80er, Anfang 90er.
Da gab es noch keine 686er. Da sind wir ja bei 2,86 oder 3,86.
Fach den Hardware-Opa. Der hatte das alles noch zu Hause liegen.
Nee, hatte mit PC nichts zu tun.
Ich hatte einen 2,86er.
Irgendwo musste Xenica noch laufen.
Der erste Eigenhaber war dann tatsächlich so eine schlimme Windows 98 SE Büchse. Aber die war nie am Internet. Also deswegen...
Ist noch rein.
Die hat die Telefonbüchse nie gesehen. Insofern war das noch relativ unproblematisch.
Übernehmen Sie.
Ja, machen wir weiter hier.
Wir haben jetzt hier voll die Stru...
Haben wir die Xara-Attacke jetzt dann ordentlich durch erklärt? Ja, schon hatten wir. Kaspersky hatten wir, Last Pass hatten wir.
Genau.
Machen wir weiter mit Security.
Und zwar, die Meldung fand ich ganz interessant. Mir war das gar nicht so bewusst, aber man kann ja seine SSH-Public Keys auf seinem GitHub-Account ablegen.
Die Keys oder den Public Key?
Na, den Public Key. Und die sind dann auch öffentlich einsehbar. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum man da eigentlich seinen SSH-Key ablegen will.
Damit du dann da connecten kannst mit SSH, weil die nur Key-Only machen.
Ja, aber eigentlich legst du die eher so für, also die müssen jetzt nicht öffentlich einsehbar sein eigentlich.
Also es beschränkt den Zugriff auf das Repository sozusagen. Das heißt, man kann dann auch nur darüber mit dem Key irgendwie Zugriff halten. Also Login alleine reicht nicht, Passwort verlieren ist da.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist nicht so ganz korrekt. Also du würdest zum Beispiel, du kannst einen Deploy-Key dahin packen, damit halt irgendwelche Tools automatisiert mit der API sprechen können oder halt nicht interaktive Passworteingabe haben willst. Du kannst aber, wenn du einen Deploy-Key hast, kannst du dich trotzdem über die HTTPS-API nach wie vor mit Username und Passwort einloggen. Also im Prinzip legt man wirklich so, zum Beispiel du hast einen Build-Server, der automatisiert irgendwie da so Sachen bildet und vielleicht auch wieder zurückpusht und so und damit er das holen kann und wieder reinschieben kann, da macht man Deploy-Key und du würdest auf den Build-Server selbst diesen Private-Key dann, also das Key Pair ablegen und den Deploy-Key, den Public-Key sozusagen, da bei GitHub reinschieben.
Verstehe. Na ja, auf jeden Fall entsteht dadurch ein ganz interessantes Verzeichnis von Public-Key, weil man die wohl relativ einfach so zusammensammeln kann und das hat dann eben auch mal jemand getan. Da gibt es hier so einen schönen Blog-Eintrag, den werfe ich auch gerade mal in den Chat rein. Und hat sich dann mal sozusagen alle Public-Keys, die auf GitHub so rumliegen, einfach mal geschnappt in eine Datenbank geworfen und mal so ein bisschen geschaut, was denn nun mit diesen Keys so ist. Und das sind auch relativ viele, ja. Also 30, was war das hier? Also 30 Prozent der Leute, die irgendwie ein Commit auf GitHub gemacht haben, haben keinen Public-Key. Oder anders aus 70 Prozent aller Leute, die da ein Commit machen, haben da ein Public-Key abgelegt. Das finde ich auch sehr viel.
Ja, aber ist halt, ja, braucht man halt schon öfters mal.
Ja gut, aber das sind mal locker 1,3 Millionen Public-Keys, die da rumliegen. Und ja, dann kann man halt diesen Keys aber auch ansehen, was sie für ein Key-Type sind und was sie für eine Key-Size haben.
Die meisten machen noch RSA, ja.
Und die Key-Länge war da sehr überschaubar. Also die allermeisten haben RSA gemacht, ganz wenig DSS-Keys und vor allem die Key-Länge war bei vielen 2048, aber blieben da noch sehr viele übrig, die eben sehr kleine Key-Sizes hatten. Und naja, da waren ja so teilweise so Ausreißer mit irgendwie 256 Bits und 512 und so weiter, also relativ wenig. Ich glaube, bis 768 ist das alles noch relativ schnell erknackbar. Und ja, das haben sie dann halt auch mal gemacht und haben einfach mal ein paar Keys so gebrutforced und dann auch Zugriff auf GitHub, Repositories und so weiter.
Da kann ich mich kurz einklinken. Und zwar hier steht jetzt auch The Debian Bug Bites Again. Und zwar, wie hier auch schon steht, gab es bei Debian mal ein Bug, dass du, wenn du nach random data gefragt hast, die du ja brauchst, um eine Key zu erzeugen, dann kam nur, wie soll man es schön sagen, eine Zahl zwischen 1 und 32.000 könnte man das jetzt nennen. Also man konnte nur 32.000 verschiedene Keys generieren. Und das sollten ja ein paar mehr sein, weil ich kann mir auch genau diese 32.000 Keys generieren. Und das hat man jemals gemacht und hat diese Keys, die da erzeugt wurden, genommen, um zu gucken, ob da und die als Bitcoin-Adresse, also Bitcoin-Keys sozusagen, erzeugt und hat dann alles sich abkassiert, was auf diesen Kontos lag. Und es waren wohl einige Bitcoins. Und ja, kann ich dir nachher noch mehr erzählen, weil ich weiß auch, wer es war.
Und noch eine Edition. Hier es gab beim vorletzten Kongress, gab es ja so ein Team, die nMap neu gehackt haben in Schnell hier. Scann the whole Internet in Hafenauer. Wie hieß das Tool nochmal? ZMap. Und die haben ja in ihrem Vortrag auch geguckt und gemacht und haben mal halt so, sich mit, also haben halt mal gescannt und haben halt auch Public Keys gescannt im ganzen Internet. Und hatten ja da auch festgestellt, dass ganz viele irgendwie so vom WRT oder irgendwo, da wurde halt immer so der Standard Key benutzt. Also beziehungsweise, wenn das Linux das erste Mal hochfahre, irgendwie sowas war das, da ist halt random, def random noch nicht initialisiert oder kriegt halt so den ersten State. Und dann waren da halt Millionen und Abermillionen Key mit dem gleichen Seat da draußen. Also auch da mit diesem ZMap, da kann man sogar nicht nur bei GitHub gucken, da kann man im ganzen Internet gucken.
Der alte Klassiker, für gute Krypto brauchst du guten Zufall.
Ja und was halt auch bei GitHub noch im Spezialen passiert ist, da haben sich Leute die Rails-Repositories und Projekte angehoben. Man kann ja so nach Programmiersprachen auch filtern und so weiter. Und bei Rails, die kümmern sich ja schon sehr viel um so Cookie Security und Salted, Hashes und das und das alles. Aber was sie dir eigentlich immer sagen am Anfang, hier editier mal deinen Cookie Secret, also füg da mal irgendeinen Random Garbage rein. Und das machen halt die wenigsten nicht. Und am Anfang hat das Rails halt so immer einen Default-Wert gehabt. Und dann haben die sozusagen nach den Rails-Repos geguckt, die sozusagen diesen Default-Wert, weil es ist ja voll durchsuchbar jetzt alle Repos bei GitHub, die diesen Default Cookie Secret noch drin haben. Beziehungsweise, selbst wenn sie ihn geändert haben, wenn du das mit eincheckst in ein öffentliches Repo, dann sieht den halt jeder. Und dann kannst du halt deine Cookies forgen und zusammen basteln, wie du willst. Und kannst dich halt mühelos in jede Webplattform quasi dann so reinhexen. Und das ist auch wieder so die alte Geschichte. Also so Sicherheit gibt es einfach nicht for free und nicht mit einem Buttonklick. Man muss auch selber immer noch so eine kleine, gedankliche Leistung mit einbringen, damit das wirklich sicher ist. Und nicht einfach alles in die Cloud schieben und yeah, yeah, yeah, ja, passt schon. Weil die Maschinen lesen jetzt mit, das ist das Problem. Ich sage auch immer den Studenten, wenn die so über hier Paranoia fragen und wer will mich hacken und ist das nicht alles total gefährlich, ich sage denen ja auch immer, das sind keine Menschen, die euch hacken, das sind Programme, denen ist auch total scheißegal, wer ihr seid und was ihr macht. Die scannen einfach das ganze Internet und wenn euer Passwort scheiß ist, dann nehmen die euer Passwort auseinander und dann wird euer Rechner geohnt und dann wird der Auto oder der Typ, der das einsetzt, der wird dann per E-Mail notifiziert. So, lieber Herr... Just one more dummy found.
Überweisen Sie einen Bitcoin hier und dann entschlüssel ich Ihre Daten.
Also das ist halt auch immer...
Hatte da nicht noch nicht so ein Typ das freiwillig aufgegeben? Fand ich auch sehr lustig.
Sie wissen nicht, wer es war, aber es wurde sozusagen...
Ist auch die Frage, wie freiwillig. Könnte durch das sein, dass die russische Magde rausgefunden hat, wenn es war, und ihm gesagt, ihm war Betonschuhe angezogen, hat gesagt, so jetzt tu mal raus oder so.
Anyway, das ist auf jeden Fall so eine... Beim einfachen Mann und bei der einfachen Frau da draußen im Internet immer noch so ein Missverständnis, dass ja, also hinter mir, wer soll denn hinter mir her sein? Die Programme, die machen da keinen Unterschied.
Derselbe Bot, der auch hinter allen anderen her ist.
Das sind übrigens die Leute, die dann so Sorgen haben, die noch drei Sätze davor gesagt haben, ja, also Überwachung ist jetzt nicht so, ich hab ja nichts zu verbergen.
War doch nicht letztes Mal so, wenn sie nicht verbergen hat, warum machen sie da beim Sex den Vorhang vor oder irgendwie so?
Ich hab da gerade wenigstens was von jungen Leuten höre, ist meine Standardreplik darauf immer, okay, du hast nichts zu verbergen. Wie ist dein Facebook-Passwort?
Ja, gut, ich meine, nichts verbergen und so in eine Situation geraten, wo sich jemand anderes als einer selbst ausgeben, sind schon noch mal zweite Debatten.
Ja, also hier so mit, aber das geht ja dann auch.
Nö, aber du kannst einfach mal nach den Fotos auf dem Telefon fragen einfach.
Genau, darf ich mal dein Telefon haben?
Du hast ja offensichtlich nichts zu verbergen.
Lass mich mal deine Fotos sehen, ja, muss ja nicht mal nackt Fotos sein.
Ja, also kurz gesagt, wenn ihr SSH benutzt, erstmal alles gar kein Problem, aber wenn ihr irgendwie eure SSH-Keys auf Github packt oder auf andere öffentliche Systeme?
Also ich mach ja seit ich tippen kann, seitdem ich ein Terminal aufmachen kann, oder seitdem ich SSH benutzen kann, mach ich ja schon immer 4096 Bit-Keys. Haben mich früher immer alle belächelt. Und jetzt bin ich immer noch fort dabei.
Ok, mal SSH. Wir sind ja hier der Fachpodcast für Windows-Betriebssysteme. Deswegen, nur weil ich das neulich mal gelesen habe, jetzt wäre natürlich die Windows-Freaks wieder die Kommentare zu schwimmen. Welche Windows-Freaks? Es ist wohl so, dass jetzt Microsoft eingesehen hat, dass das nützliche Tool ist. Und damit die ganzen Windows-User mal von dem dreckigen Putty wegkommen, liefert Windows jetzt mit Windows 10 wohl selber einen nativen SSH-Client aus. Und nicht bloß einen Client, sondern auch einen Server. Du kannst in eine Windows-10-Kiste angeblich reinen SSH an.
Wie, das ging noch nicht?
Nee, mit irgendwelchen Zusatz-Tools und tralala. Aber es ist nicht so wie USX, dass da SSH und SSH-Dimension dabei sind.
Echt?
Mit Windows Remote Desktop ist doch...
Hab ich gerade neulich gelesen und dachte so, okay, gut. Die kommen eh ganz gut aus dem Knopf. Habt ihr mitgekriegt, dass zum Beispiel Microsoft eine ganze Menge von diesen Veranstaltungen, die so um die WWDC herum sind, wie zum Beispiel AltKomf und irgendwelche anderen Sachen, dass die die mitsponsern? Microsoft.
Ja, weiß ich.
Ich mach die seit Jahren. Ja, finde ich cool. Darf man mal laut sagen.
Nicht so wie Abfeld, die dann der Alternativkonferenz sagen, sie dürfen den Stream, den Keynote-Spiel...
Ja, haben sie ihn ja dann doch erlaubt, aber trotzdem erst mal so. Die haben auf Altcom die ganzen Sessions gezeigt und so. War so kurz vor der Angst.
Ja, das wäre auch ein bisschen albern gewesen, aber ich meine, dass Microsoft tief in die Taschen greift und sich da überall reinschmeichelt, das ist ja schon seit längerem so, seitdem sie im Prinzip auf dieses ganze Azure-Zeug abfahren.
Hast du gerade Lust, deine Verhörlampe mal ein bisschen wegzudrehen?
Kann ich machen.
Insbesondere dann, wenn du...
Die Zeugen ist entlastet.
Gut, sind wir noch bei SSH? Ja, sind wir. Aber jetzt können wir das Kapitel auch glaube ich zumachen, falls sie noch nicht gekommen sind.
Aber da war jetzt ein Bug, oder war das nur, man soll da ein bisschen aufpassen, was man da für Kies holt?
Das war eher Data Mining und...
Genau, es war einfach mal eine Analyse, dass sehr viele von diesen Keys da einfach zu schwach sind. Und immerhin haben die es hier geschafft, Zugriff auf Spotify, Public Repos, Yandex, die Krypto-Libraries von Python, Django, Python Core, also Government UK, Public Repos.
Und das sind die, wo er Zugang bekommen hat, weil die halt ihren Key mit D-Gran erzeugt haben und er sozusagen diese Standardlist dann 32.000 Keys mal durchprobiert hat.
Genau, bzw. ich glaube, diesen 256-Bit-Key hat er irgendwie da oben stets in 25 Minuten auf einem i5 mit 2,4 Gigahertz refakturiert. Also die ganz kleinen Keys gingen so und die größeren Keys gingen dann halt eben, wenn sie von diesem Libian Bug befallen waren und da halt mal mit einem schlechten Salt erzeugt worden sind.
Schlechtes Salz ohne Jod und Flur.
Ohne Jod ist F-Görnchen.
Genau, bleiben wir noch kurz bei Krypto. Es gibt nämlich die GPG-Tools für den Mac. Jetzt endlich in einem Final-Release für Yosemite.
Die sind immer ein Jahr hinterher irgendwie, kann das sein? Also genau richtig.
Ich auch.
Also jetzt kannst du upgraden, Hucke.
Ich benutze ja gerade nicht so richtig aktiv GPG.
Ja, warum wohl?
Naja, ja, auch.
Ey, Facebook macht das jetzt auch.
Man könnte Apple mal sagen, wenn sie ja so dick in Security machen und dann Privacy und so, dann sie vielleicht in ihrem Mail ab, dass man so ein bisschen mehr supporten würden, dass nämlich GPG nicht so ein Jahr später rauskommt. Bei Apple hätte ja gerne, dass man immer das neue Stores benutzt. Wer weiß, wie viele Leute nur deswegen nicht auf Yosemite gegangen sind.
Vielleicht 50.
Sie sollen einfach mal hier, mal im Betriebssystem eine Möglichkeit schaffen, dass ich mir so eine S-Mime-Zertifikate erzeugen kann.
Das hast du schon seit Jahren drin. Es gibt sogar einen Keychain, wie nennt man das, so ein Assistant, der das macht.
Aber es soll selbst sein und dann kommt wieder der Schlagstock.
Egal, bei Mail nicht so notwendigerweise.
Certificate Assistant, genau.
Kannst du das schon seit Jahren machen, ist schon ewig drin.
Das hab ich sogar im Windows.
Ich hab einen Certificate Assistant, der ist nicht mehr die gültige.
Nein, das ist in der Keychain-Geschichte. Da guckst du oben am Menü.
Was?
In der vorhin gedissten Keychain. Da gibt es einen Keychain, wie nennt sich der Ding? Keychain Access heißt das Ding. Und da guckst du mal am Menü.
Bei Keychain Access, nicht unter File oder so, da gibt es den Certificate Assistant.
Nee, bei Keychain Access. Da kannst du eine eigene CA damit machen und so weiter und so fort. Jetzt ist da schon lange drin.
Und der Default ist, wenn du Create a New Certificate, dann ist auch der Default Certificate Typed as My Self Signed Route.
Was ist denn das?
Ich überlege schon gerade, das ist echt ein sehr interessantes Bild.
Ja, die Sendung wäre für eine halbe Stunde angehalten.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, wo...
Du hättest auch mal ruhig jemanden fragen können, der anderen davon hat.
Mach ich doch gerade. Ja, aber wie gilt denn das dann? Das ist ja nur Self Signed Route Kram.
Das ist ein Zertifikat. Wer es unterschrieben hat, ist immer noch eine andere Frage. Übrigens auch zu dieser Geschichte von Let's Encrypt vorhin.
Wird denn das dann akzeptiert?
Gerade beim Mail ist es so, dass sehr viel akzeptiert wird, was der drüben einmal gesehen hat. Wenn der drüben einmal gesehen hat, sagt er, ja, das ist Tim, das glaube ich, dann nimmt er seine Keychain auf. Wer das unterschrieben hat, ist eigentlich nicht so richtig wichtig. Wenn du so ein Self Signed Ding hast, blökt der Empfänger schon mal so ein bisschen rum, aber dann kann er sagen, doch, die Mail ist von Tim. Dann ist der Drops auch gelutscht und ist auch fein.
Deswegen ist ja dein Keychain auch voll mit lauter Keys von Leuten, die dir irgendwann mal eine Mail geschrieben haben.
Ich finde, dein Adressbuch ist voll. Dein Keychain ist voll und dein Adressbuch auch. Du kannst nämlich in deinem Adressbuch auch sehen, von wem du Certificates hast und so weiter und so fort. Ich habe erzählt, dass ich seit Anfang des Jahres nur Encryption anhabe. Wer jetzt immer noch einen Web-Mailer benutzt, der nicht mit den SMIME-signierten Nachrichten klarkommt, der kann mich mal. Und ich kriege jetzt sehr viel signiertes Zeug, sogar witzigerweise von der Deutschen Telekom. Man glaubt das gar nicht. Selbst die können das, Tim.
16.06.2016 gilt das jetzt hier bei den Folten.
Ja, du kannst jetzt noch ansagen, du kannst dich jetzt noch assoziieren, diese Zertifikat mit deinen E-Mail-Accounts. Das machst du auch in der Keychain Access. Wenn du das anmachst, in der Mail ab, kannst du sagen, wenn ich jetzt den Tim-At-so-und-so-Account nehme, dann möchte ich gerne mit folgendem Zertifikat. Äh, nee, du sagst glaube ich auch. Es gibt irgendwo diese Assoziationen, wo man dazu ansteht.
Also da steht jetzt schon eine Mail-Adresse drin.
Naja, die muss ja auch in dem Zertifikat drin sein, aber du kannst ja in dem Zertifikat mehrere Adressen haben. Ihr solltet dringend mal eine Nicht-CRE-Sendung, weil du machst ja kein CRE mehr, mal über Zertifikate und den ganzen Blödsinn machen.
Ich hab gerade angekündigt, dass ich hier noch alles mache.
Ich hab's eben schon angeschnitten. Let's Encrypt nochmal. Bei der ganzen Diskussion, wer euch eure Zertifikate unterschreibt, ist es vollkommen irrelevant für die Security, nämlich für die Krypto eures Servers, wer euch das Ding unterschreibt. An alle, die jetzt mit dem Thema erst mal anfangen, ist vollkommen scheißegal, weil ihr generiert euch selber den Private Key und der ist Key für die Krypto. Das ist das wichtige Ding, mit dem ihr eure Krypto absichert. Das andere Teil ist nur dafür da, um sicherzustellen oder nicht um sicherzustellen, um nachweisen zu wollen oder zu können, dass der, jene, der die Webseite betreibt, auch der wirklich derjenige ist, oder wie auch immer man das jetzt interpretieren mag. Für die Authentifizierung. Aber das hat nichts mit der Verschlüsselung oder der Krypto zu tun, sondern da an dieser Stelle ist nur ein reiner Transportmechanismus das Zertifikat für euren Public Key. Und die ganze Security hängt nur an eurem Key. Das heißt, ihr könnt euch sogar eure Zertifikat von der NSA persönlich unterschreiben lassen, deswegen wäre die Key trotzdem nicht schlechter.
Aber nochmal kurz zurück zu GPG. Ich hab jetzt auch mal gedacht, ich mach mir mal einen neuen Key, aber ich bin auch noch nicht so auf den 4096 oder keine Ahnung, was man jetzt auch immer nehmen sollte, aber ich denke, wer war ein neuer Key angesagt? Und das sollte man ja sorgfältig planen. Es gibt ja immer wieder allerlei Parameter, von denen man nicht so genau weiß, was sie jetzt für eine Bedeutung haben. Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt hier in dieser GPG Keychain, von den GPG Tools, einen neuen Key erzeugen lassen möchte. Dann wird mir RSA und RSA angeboten, oder DSA und Elgammal.
Nicht Blasfish? War nicht Blowfish da auch mal mit dabei?
Blowfish ist ja Encryption selbst. Das sind ja die Public-Private-Algorithmen. Der Blowfish kommt dann eine Stufe später.
Der Blowfish ist der symmetrische Cypher.
Ja, aber was soll man denn jetzt nehmen? Also, naja, DSA oder RSA?
Oder Gammal.
Hier steht ja DSA und Elgammal. Das gehört ja hier zusammen.
Mir war so, als wenn mal gesagt wurde, RSA ist durch und man soll immer DSA machen.
Warum ist das dann hier der Default?
Ja, durch und nicht durch. Ich bin jetzt nicht so in dieser GPG-Szene drin, aber in der anderen SSL-Szene ist RSA noch lange nicht durch. Insbesondere dann, wenn man es halt eben noch schön...
Ich meine, was heißt denn das? Wenn ich jetzt ein DSA-Key mache, dann gibt es Software da draußen, die denen gar nicht damit arbeiten kann?
Sagen wir mal so, ich glaube mal, das RSA, das ist immer die Frage, was jetzt... Du hast ja den berühmten Least Common Denominator, der kleinste gemeinsame Vielfacher, sozusagen, also der kleinste Nenner. Heißt das in Deutsch so? Und RSA ist mit Sicherheit, da das sozusagen das Urzeug ist, was da mal drin war, ist sozusagen das, was jeder Trop da draußen verstehen sollte. Das ist das Minimum. DSA ist aber glaube ich auch schon ein bisschen älter. Er hat auch schon, fängt schon leicht an zu grinsen an den Ecken. Ihr wisst auch nicht.
Genau, also ich würde sagen, frag mal jemand, der sich damit auskennt, weil ich hab auch, also das ist bei mir lange her, dass ich mal so im CCC saß und mir denjenigen geschnappt hat, der da gerade total drin war und der Key ist schon lange nicht mehr gültig.
In der SSH-Szene ist DSA schon länger out. Kommt man jetzt mal nachklicken, warum hat mich aber bisher noch nicht so berührt?
Also RSA beruht auf dem Faktorisieren von großen Nummern. Und DSA basiert auf dem Discrete Logarism Problem.
Ja, aber es gab, also ich kann mich erinnern, ich hab daneben so einen Top-Checker-Bunny mal im Club gesessen und hab mir das erklären lassen und da war irgendwas mit DSA und RSA, was nicht so komplett intuitiv war und es hat da auch irgendwie einen guten Grund, ob das jetzt immer noch valide ist und so weiter.
Wie gesagt, in der SSH-Szene hat sich diese DSA-Geschichte so ein bisschen erledigt schon vor einer Zeit.
Also frag mal hier einen von den Krypto-Freaks aus dem Club, die können dir vielleicht mal auch einen schönen CRE noch bescheren dazu.
Das steht im Internet auch ganz gut.
Ja, aber ist ja im CRE. Der Tim kriegt ein paar Flatterklicks, kann sich wieder ein Nutella-Brot kaufen und dann ist auch...
Ihr seid gar keine richtigen Hacker. Ihr wisst nicht, wie man GPG-Keys macht.
GPG ist doch eh.
Naja, also ich denke, an diesem Zeitpunkt ist die Kommentarspalte dieser Sendung in unserem Blog auch schon mit guten Ratschlägen gefüllt. Und wenn nicht...
DSA kam auch deswegen auf, weil RSA noch patentiert war. Und man es nicht nutzen durfte. Nicht überall.
Ach, da gab es doch dieses geile Delfin-T-Shirt, bei ThinkGeeked oder so, mit dem RSA-Code, als Delfin so in ASCII obfuscated. Und dann war es total cool, mit diesem Delfin-Shirt rumzulaufen, weil der Code eigentlich gar nicht hätte da drauf sein dürfen. Nerd-Shirts. So, jetzt mal wieder was Unterhaltsames.
Noch unterhaltsamer.
Viel und noch viel unterhaltsamer.
Wo wir gerade über E-Mail gesprochen haben. Soll ich noch mal eins reingrätschen davon?
Irgendeine Top-Level. Wählen Sie eine Top-Level-Kategorie.
Naja, hier bei E-Mail würde jetzt zum Beispiel dieses Postbox-Thema ja nochmal gut reinpassen, weil ich habe ja schon öfters davon berichtet, ich benutze das ja glaube ich seit Version 2. Ein E-Mail-Programm namens Postbox, und das benutze ich deswegen, weil es sich nativer anfühlt oder mehr wie eine OSX-App, sondern coolere Features hat als Thunderbird, obwohl Thunderbird ursprünglich mal als Basis hatte. Und im Gegensatz zu Apple-Mail, was prinzipiell vielleicht noch ein bisschen hübscher ist, halt auch E-Map vollständig sprechen kann und auch nicht so komische To-Do-Listen und Folder und so weiter auf deinem E-Map-Zahler anlegt. Du hast halt mehr Kontrolle in generell, würde ich sagen. Und ich habe Postbox 3 von der Weile mal gekauft. Also es ist halt auch so Payware, Shareware. Und dann habe ich lange nichts mehr gehört. Da gab es keine Updates und irgendwie der Twitter-Account hat monatelang nicht mehr getrunken. Und ich dachte, okay, vielleicht waren die einfach zu sehr da auch in ihrer Nische und alle benutzen Apple Mail und interessiert halt keinen. Und dann kam plötzlich, mache ich meinen Postbox auf, da ist ja dann immer so hier auf der einen Seite vielleicht so irgendwie, wenn die mal News haben, kommt dann so ein kleines Bildchen und dann kam so hier, Postbox 4 ist da. Und dann dachte ich, na, da haben sie sich aber sehr zurückgehalten die letzte Zeit. Und weil ich das Programm halt ja jeden Tag benutze, das ist mein primärer Mail-Klient seit Jahren, habe ich dann den mal runtergeladen, ausprobiert und dann auch die, was weiß ich, wie viel Dollar sie haben wollen, es waren jetzt nicht so viele, gleich hinterher geworfen. Jetzt so krasse neue Features, die mich jetzt unbedingt beeindrucken, die gibt es jetzt nicht, die haben im Wesentlichen einfach noch ein bisschen mehr an der Usability geschraubt, also von Kleinigkeiten, wie wenn zum Beispiel ein Newsletter reinkommt, dann fischen sie den Unsubscribe-Button dir gleich raus und zeigen ihn dann gleich so rechts oben an oder so. Ihr Filtering ist noch schicker, sie haben jetzt auch Spotlight, die Integration verbessert, das war nämlich vorher etwas dürftig, jetzt mittlerweile kannst du da auch so richtig schön mit Spotlight drin suchen. Auch so dieses ganze Handling von Attachments und Filtern und Suchen und alles ringsrum aufpoliert im Vergleich zur Version 3.0 und wer vorher Postbox mal ausprobiert hatte und so dachte, ja, ist schon besser als Thunderbird, aber immer noch nicht so geil wie Apple Mail, könnte sich das ja 30 Tage nochmal angucken, weil ist jetzt auf jeden Fall fluffiger geworden und also definitiv besser als Version 3.0. Ja, viel mehr muss ich dazu jetzt eigentlich auch gar nicht sagen, weil die Features auf der Webseite und so, die könnt ihr euch selber durchlesen und einfach 30 Tage ausprobieren. Ich kann nur sagen, für mich funktioniert das auch, wenn es halt immer noch nicht 100%ig vielleicht so geil ist wie das Apple Mail oder so, wobei Apple Mail halt im Wesentlichen so ein bisschen shiny aussieht und eine wirkliche USX ab ist, aber halt hintenrum vielleicht nicht so brilliert.
Gibt es da Mailing-Listen-Support?
Was heißt Mailing-Listen-Support?
Naja, dass er mal so einer Mail auch ansieht, dass sie aus einer Mailing-Liste ist und vielleicht auch selber gleich mal irgendwo weg...
Unsubscribe-Buttons und so?
Nein, mir geht es nicht so... Wegsortieren, genau. Ich habe bisher noch kein Programm gesehen, was das tut, aber ich wünsche mir dieses Feature immer.
Du meinst, was man die Header nutzt, wo auch hier die Mailing-Listen-Reply-Adresse steht und so was?
Also auf jeden Fall hier bei der Elex hier, bei der Erlang-Mailing-Liste gibt es halt auf jeden Fall zumindest auch schon direkt den Unsubscribe-Button für die Liste von Postbox rausgesucht. Also die gucken schon in die Header und...
Ein Mail-Programm, was in ihre Mail schaut.
Genau.
Das ist ja schon im Shit.
Und wollen wir gleich noch hier die ganzen anderen Apps auch noch schnell durchhacken, dann haben wir das so, das locker fluffige Themenspektrum abgearbeitet.
Mal schnell? Du meinst, du möchtest jetzt zum Audio vorstoßen?
Oder auch dieses andere da so?
Aber Audio ist doch schon mehr Kunst, die haben doch noch so viel Technik da.
Ja, nee, das ist Technik. Das ist Hardcore-Technik, das ist Fuzzmeasure 4. Genau.
Fuzzmeasure 4?
Das ist ein Programm von der tollen Firma supermegaultragroovy.com, also so heißt die Webseite.
Ich meine, es gibt echt keine coolen Domains mehr.
Und die haben ja schon ein Programm gemacht, das heißt CAPO und das ist so ein Programm zum Gitarre lernen, um Songs zu verlangsamen, ohne die Tonhöhe zu verändern und so weiter und so fort. Und die haben ein Produkt, das wusste ich lange Zeit gar nicht, das hat mir der Simon hier aus der Raumfahrtagentur mal gezeigt. Und damit kannst du so Raumakustik-Analyse machen. Und zwar richtig geil, lecker, native, OSX-Apps, schicke Graphen, also Waterfall-Diagramme, bis der Arzt kommt und so richtig schön. Das was man halt damit macht im Wesentlichen, man kauft sich so ein Kugelmikro, also was so oben so eine ganz dünne Spitze hat, stellt das in die Mitte von seinem Raum, hängt dieses Fuzzmeasure an seinem Audio-Interface. Dann machst du das nochmal und kannst sozusagen diffen, ob du irgendwelche von diesen Problemen auch behoben hast. Und das ist einfach das coolste Programm, was es in diesem Sinne gibt, weil es einfach schon in dem Modus, wo man eigentlich als, also so wie wir jetzt vielleicht Null Ahnung davon hat, da bringt das halt auch schon was, weil es gibt schon erstmal so Default Presets, wo du sofort irgendwie ein bisschen Manual lesen sehen kannst, worauf es zu achten gibt. Und es gibt halt auch genug so Audioprofis, die das halt auch wirklich professionellen Einsatz haben, um Räume oder Hallen oder sonst was einzumessen und im Zweifel gegen zu regeln. In der neuen Version sieht das so aus, als würde es einem auch noch ein bisschen mehr sagen. Bei der vorherigen Version war es so, man musste halt schon so ein bisschen Manual lesen und dann stand halt zu jedem Test oder zu jeder Messung, was die bringt und worauf es zu achten gilt. Aber das ist wirklich einfach ein wirklich sau cooles Programm. Ich weiß gar nicht, es ist nicht super erschwinglich auch. Ich glaube die Personal License, genau die ist 99 für Non-Professional Used by Hobbyists and Enthusiasts und für Professionals kostet es dann 499. 99. Aber es gibt nur Demo-Versionen, da gehen dann halt irgendwie nur drei Tests oder so, wenn ich mich rechnen sinne, oder es geht alles für 30 Tage irgendwie so. Das reicht halt im Zweifel vielleicht auch schon mal aus, um, wenn man schon so ein Kugelmikro hat, mal seinen Raum so ein bisschen zu auszuleuchten. Ja, und weil das viele Leute nicht kennen, inklusive mir, ich habe das auch lange Zeit nicht gewusst, dass es das überhaupt gibt, dann checkt das mal aus. Richtig krass. Und eine kleine App hätte ich denn noch?
Wo wir schon über Audio reden.
Das ist eine wirklich schöne Überleitung, Tim.
Vielen Dank, dass du auf deinen Sprechanspruch verzichtet hast. Auphonic, unser allgemeiner Lieblingsdienst.
Ich versuche mich stumm zu schalten.
Du musst einfach nur auf das A drauf drücken.
Das ist aber nicht dauerhaft.
Machst du mich mal ganz kurz einfach?
Achso, so richtig, warte mal, du bist hier.
Auf vier.
Genau, weg bist du. Also, Auphonic hat ja vor einiger Zeit, da hatten wir auch glaube ich schon mal darüber gesprochen, diese Möglichkeit geschaffen, Multitrack-Aufnahmen abmixen zu lassen. Und das ist ja ein relativ dickes Brett, was da gebohrt werden muss. Und das wurde dann auch gebohrt. Das heißt, man kann, ich mach das hier zum Beispiel. Also Freak Show wird jetzt hier in eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs Spuren aufgenommen. Und all diese Spuren habe ich danach hochgeladen. Und dann macht halt der Auphonic Dienst so seine Magic. Dauert allerdings ganz schön lange. Also ist im Vergleich zu der normalen Bearbeitung einer Stereospur schon eine erhebliche Zeitsteigerung. Und dementsprechend muss man sich das halt gut überlegen.
Aber das Telefon vibriert unerlaubt auf dem Tisch.
So und jetzt gibt es auf Auphonic Multitrack die Funktionalität, die es in der Webseite gibt, gibt es jetzt auch als Standalone-App. Das heißt, man kann ohne jetzt hochzuladen, weil das ist ja dann auch nochmal ein Problem, wenn du viel mehr Daten dann auf einmal zusammenträgst. Also es ist nicht monumental viel mehr, weil gerade hier, ich nehme halt mit Flak auf und wenn halt dann Stille ist auf bestimmten Spuren, dann fällt da auch nicht unbedingt so viel Daten an. Aber da reicht ja dann meistens auch nur so ein leichtes Rauschen und dann greift da Flak auch nicht mehr so gut. Wie auch immer, die Auphonic Multitrack-App, das heißt App, also das Programm. Wann fing das eigentlich an?
Applikation.
Genau, die Applikation, das Programm, die Software, das Tool, das kann man sich halt kaufen und dann hat man diese ganze Multitrack-Downmix-Funktionalität im Programm und dann kann man das halt schön tunen und vor allem, wenn man halt viele, viele Chores hat, die auch ordentlich zum Schwitzen bringen.
Und wie viel kostet das?
Das ist halt eine gute Frage.
Weil der Single-Client, der war ja auch schon, sagen wir mal, nicht jetzt so günstig. Also ich hab mal mir das angeguckt und dachte mir, oh, ist ja doch teuer und billig ist ja auch mal so eine Sache, aber war jetzt zumindest, hat mich nicht sofort den Kaufreiz bei mir getriggert.
Nee, das ist ja dann auch immer sehr relativ. Ich meine, sowas muss man auch brauchen können. Single User für Single Human Non-Commercial ist 69 Euro und die Commercial License ist 300 Euro.
Ja und das ist halt, also ich meine, beim Podcast, wo ich jetzt so Flatter hab und so, dann ist das ja nicht so richtig Non-Commercial, ne? Was ist denn das jetzt? Also ich meine, wenn ich damit Geld verdiene, aber das halt, um 300 Euro zum Beispiel mit Flatter zusammenzukriegen bei meinem 300-Hertz-Podcast, da muss ich schon eine lange Zeit ins Mikro süßen, damit das zusammenkommt, ne?
Da schreibst du halt mal eine Mail und ich glaube, du hast ja ganz gute Chancen, als Non-Commercial runterzukommen, weil hier geht's nicht darum, dass du irgendwo, finde ich, verdienst mit irgendwas, sondern ob du das Tool konkret als...
Achso, hier steht ja aber auch sogar, your annual gross revenue exceeds 15.000 Dollar. Okay, weil ich wollte gerade sagen, das wäre eigentlich so die Floskel, die finde ich ja bei Reaper so sympathisch auch. Wir haben ja auch so ein Lizenzmodell, wenn du irgendwie im Jahr weniger als, was weiß ich, so viel 1000 Dollar verdienst, dann hier nehmen die discounted License für 69 und ansonsten kostet... Okay, haben sie auch gemacht, okay, dann ist ja alles cool, weil dann ist alles super. Okay, 69 kauf ich mir. Geil.
Ja, und dann hat man einen Multitrack Downmix, das Ding kann halt auch viel, was das Webseitensystem auch kann, also du kannst die ganzen Parameter, Lautstärkeparameter etc. beeinflussen, du kannst das Ausgabeformat genau bestimmen, also kann nicht nur Flak, sondern kann auch Waff und Waff mit Float und Pipapo machen.
Aber der Level Batch Processor, ist der da mit drin oder braucht man das separat?
Naja, das macht eigentlich dasselbe, nur eben auf mehreren Dateien. Warum das jetzt sozusagen zwei separate Tools sind, ist wahrscheinlich einfach eine praktische Entscheidung, aber im Prinzip macht es, es levelt ja auch, nur es macht es halt über mehrere Tracks.
Ja, aber die Namen suggerieren mir jetzt quasi, dass der Leveler-Batch-Processor, der klingt nach so Batch-Processing und irgendwie so Wump Wump Wump und Leveling und der andere, der Auphonic Multitrack-Professor, der klingt halt so, als würde er sich speziell um das Multitrack-Problem kümmern und jetzt nicht vielleicht ums Batchen und ums Levelen, aber das lese ich mir in meiner Ruhe nochmal durch.
Ist alles dabei.
Mit so so einem Schaf.
Genau, Apple Leveler, Crossgate und so weiter, kann man alles einschalten.
Da war wieder ein Rollkoffer, Dennis, hast du gehört?
Das war nicht Mitte hier.
Hier gibt es auch ein paar Terroristen. Unsere Sympathisanten.
Da kannst du nicht so schwer sein, so ordentliche Gummirollen für so einen Rollkoffer zu machen, oder? Die Skater schaffen das doch auch.
Ja, auch die Flightcase-Hersteller und so, die schaffen das auch. Also die so richtig blauen Wackelrollen, die auch so an diesen Cases dann immer so dran sind.
Die gibt es auch. Es gibt die richtig ruhigen, die sind aber auch in der Preisklasse einfach echt noch mal eine ganz andere Nummer. Ich rumpel tatsächlich auch immer noch mit meinem Rollkoffer.
Also bei mir in meinem Haus geht es noch, wenn ich so von Leuten höre, die wirklich so ein paar diese Mietwohnungen hier weißt schon haben, was jetzt nicht mehr so erlaubt ist, was man jetzt anmelden muss eigentlich. Ferienwohnungen, genau. Ja, wo dann wirklich alle drei Tage jemand Neues mit Rollkoffer kommt und dann kriegst du halt schon irgendwann die Krise. Und meine Straße ist auch, hörst du oft so, siehst du auch. Ich kenne jeden in meiner Straße, ich weiß, wer da nicht hingehört.
Jeden in deiner Straße?
Es ist eine Straße.
Du erkennst sie am Klang ihrer Rollkoffer.
Ich kenne auch die Nasen alle auf meinem Landsitz. Es gibt nämlich auch bloß eine Straße da.
Jetzt noch eine kleine App, dann haben wir die Sektion zumindest doch einigermaßen gut bewältigt. Und zwar gibt es ja für MySQL auf OSX einen Client, der kostenlos ist, schon seit eh und je und der auch ziemlich geil. Das ist einer der coolsten DB-Management-Tools, und zwar Sequel Pro oder Sequel Pro. Auch dieser Client, also ich weiß nicht, ich glaube mittlerweile wird der gesponsert von irgendeiner Bude. Aber der ist schon immer kostenlos und schon immer gut. Dem müsste man eigentlich auch noch ein bisschen Geld in den Topf tun, wenn er jetzt nicht gesponsert sein sollte. Das Problem ist, leider ist das eben nur für MySQL oder MySQL und die Leute, die jetzt Postgres favorisieren, von denen es ja immer mehr gibt, aus guten Gründen, die hatten da schon immer das Nachsehen. Also da gibt es ja dieses PG-Admin, das ist ja wirklich eine Katastrophe von einem User in der Face. Da kann man zwar alles drin regeln und so, aber es ist...
Aber man will nicht.
Das trifft es ganz gut, glaube ich.
Vor allen Dingen, bis du halt mal den Knopf gefunden hast, der dir ein einfaches Query oder so vielleicht abnimmt oder irgendwie eine Einstellung, da ist schon mal ein halber Tag rum, wenn man es länger nicht gemacht hat.
Ich bin ja da ein Sucker für das Command Line Interface, wie immer.
Ja, das geht auch. Aber manchmal will ich sehen. Das ist schon auch manchmal toll. Und da habe ich mal letztens wieder gegoogelt, weil ich jetzt gerade wieder ein Projekt mache, wo PostgreSQL eine Rolle spielt. Und habe tatsächlich auch ein 2, 3 neue Clients gefunden, die so alle jetzt nicht an das Sequel Pro rankommen vom Feature-Umfang. Aber eine fand ich jetzt zumindest ganz sympathisch, die hieß Postico. Wird auch von einem deutschen, ich glaube sogar Freak Show-Hörer entwickelt. Zumindest habe ich ihm mal ein paar Bugreports gleichgeschickt, hat er auch sofort gefixt. Und auch Feature-Wünsche hat er schon angeregt entgegengenommen. Und ja, kann ich mal so als kleine Empfehlung reinschmeißen, wer sich lange Zeit jetzt auch wieder nicht mit der Frage beschäftigt hat, weil der seit eh und je gab es eigentlich nie einen ordentlichen Kleinen. Und der ist zwar noch relativ simpel gestrickt, aber wenn man es mal visuell haben will und mal ein bisschen Daten so tabellarisch dargestellt eintippen und so will, dann kann man das damit schon ganz gut machen. Ich muss sagen, es ist jetzt auch kein ultimatives Schnäppchen, kostet auch stolze 39 Euro. Aber ich dachte mir mal, support your local app developer oder beziehungsweise Applikationsdeveloper und hab mir das von der Firma kaufen lassen. Damit der meine Feature-Request auch weiter einbaut. Also ja, könnt ihr ja mal auschecken und ihm vielleicht noch den einen oder anderen Feature-Wunsch entgegenbringen und im Gegenzug eine kleine Lizenz als Unterstützung kaufen. Wenn ihr euch das natürlich nützlich...
Ich muss jetzt gerade noch mit dem Router rumhacken. Wie heißt das noch mal?
Ich schick dir... Über meinem Rechner seid ihr bescheuert, Jungs.
Hinter, stopp, stopp.
Also ich schick den Link jetzt hier noch in den Chat.
Wir sind das Team, das diesmal geschafft hat, es wirklich zu bestellen.
Ach so, ist schon.
Ja, ungewöhnlicherweise.
So, waren noch irgendwelche Apps übrig? Nee, ne? Das war es doch, mit den Apps.
Schmaps.
Apps Schmaps.
Apps Schmaps. Applikationen.
Software.
Programme.
Genau. Wir müssen ja mal unseren kleinen Marker hierbei versetzen. Ich weiß nicht, das hier gefällt mir gerade irgendwie nicht so richtig als Themengebiet. Wobei ich fand das... Ach, das können wir auch mal kurz reinschmeißen. Also ich habe ja jetzt mal angefangen, ganz zartes Pflänzchen zu benutzen. Ich weiß nicht. Ich habe es mal wieder ausprobiert. Weil es jetzt so mit der Uhr losgeht, ne?
Hey Siri, lösche alle meine Kontakte.
Hey Siri funktioniert bei mir tatsächlich nicht. Ich weiß nicht...
Du musst da Strom reinmachen.
Ja, ich weiß, dass ich da Strom reinmachen muss und das auch anschalten muss. Ich habe es angeschaltet. Es ist Strom drin und ich kann so oft Hey Siri anbrüllen, wie ich möchte. Und sie reagiert einfach nicht.
Das ist ja aber schon klar, wenn wir die ganze Zeit Hey Siri sagen, das bei den Leuten im Auto die ganze Zeit Podcasts anhalten.
Ja, das ist mir schon klar. Das ist ein großer Spaß.
Ich habe da ein schönes Video zugekriegt nach der letzten Sendung. Fand ich sehr cool.
Aber sie haben auf der Keynote ja auch keine Rücksicht draufgenommen.
Das ist auch nochmal ordentlich, okay Google, lösche alle meine Kontakte sagen.
Wer heißt das von Microsoft? Die sind noch nicht in die Liga.
Zumindest habe ich festgestellt, es funktioniert nicht mehr so scheiße wie früher noch. Es ist wirklich deutlich schneller und deutlich besser geworden. Vor allem in seiner, also weniger als in seiner Siri-Form, sondern einfach, wie ich das häufiger benutze, einfach als Diktat-Software. Also das Reindiktieren von Sätzen und so weiter. Das ist dann doch in manchen Situationen für das Verschicken von Nachrichten manchmal ganz hilfreich. Und dann bin ich, ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie, aber dann bin ich irgendwie auf so eine interessante Tech-Demo gestoßen. Das muss ich jetzt hier irgendwie nochmal kurz abspielen. Das ist wirklich der Brüller.
Aber bitte nicht in voller Länge. Aber so ein bisschen.
Hier gibt es irgendwie so einen Start-up Soundhound. Und das ist so was Siri-artiges. Da gibt es hier so eine Demo für den US-Markt. Keine Ahnung.
Und auch nicht fürs iPhone, sondern für Android, oder was?
Gucken wir doch mal. Sieht so aus, genau. Und iOS ist coming soon, genau. Also die entwickeln das irgendwie als App, was auch immer sie damit bezwecken. die Demo ist aber trotzdem irgendwie beeindruckend. Ich schluss mal kurz ab.
Es ist 10.53 Uhr, der nächste Tag in Tokio. Es ist 6 Uhr, der nächste Tag in Tokio, wenn es 2 Uhr in San Francisco, Kalifornien ist.
Das springe ich mal kurz nach vorne, dann können wir uns das Ende noch mal hören. Das ist so wie ganz episch. Aber sie können vor allem extrem gut so verschiedene Anfragen miteinander kombinieren. Also genau, das war jetzt hier das mit der Mortgage.
Oder nachgefunden. Jetzt kommt das mit der Mortgage.
Aber jetzt weiß man natürlich auch nicht, weil ich meine, so wie sie es anhört, haben sie sich halt auf Geografie und Haushaltszahlen irgendwie spezialisiert, dann weiß man nicht, ob die auch ein bisschen schlauer sind, auch noch vieles andere können.
Wenn du das jetzt selber mal textuell machst mit Wolfram Alfa, der ist auch schon nicht schlecht.
Ja, das kam ja auch so ähnlich rüber wie Wolfram Alfa, was man natürlich jetzt nicht gehört hat. Das Ding hat halt auch immer diese ganzen Zahlen tabellarisch angezeigt etc. Was mich eigentlich daran fasziniert hat, ist, dass diese Demo sehr gut zeigt, wohin die Reise geht bei diesen Dingern. Ich meine, am Anfang war es ja so, hier creepy und so weiter, versteht mich nicht, la la la, dann gehen irgendwie ein, zwei Jahre, dann klappt das irgendwie so halbwegs. Und jetzt kann man halt auch immer komplexere Sachen machen und jetzt kommt ja auch diese ganze Kontext-Sache.
Jetzt kann man sie auch interaktiv nachfragen.
Das fand ich gerade besonders. Also das ist sozusagen wirklich so eine Vorstellung eines Frageproblems, da im Raum steht, die sich an einem einzigen Wort festmacht, nämlich mortgage calculation und dann füllt man sozusagen nur noch die Felder auf und kann danach aber auch sagen, ja was ist, wenn ich jetzt eine Änderung an den und den Stellen mache? Also keine Ahnung. Ich schaue in die Zukunft und ich frage mich halt, wo kommen wir denn da hin? Also ich meine, das ist ja schon, also nicht jetzt, dass ich das besonders bedrohlich empfinde, aber ich finde auch so, das hat so viel Dynamik und offensichtlich werden diese Systeme auch immer besser, wenn man sich anschaut, was Wolfram Alfa alles so ausgespuckt bekommt, wie gut Bildererkennung funktioniert, wie gut Erkennung von Diskussionspunkten, Fragestellungen etc. funktioniert.
Ob es dann am Ende nicht doch irgendwann mal die AI ist, die die Welt übernimmt, wenn die Singularität kommt, dann sind wir immer alle am Arsch.
Das kommt nicht so schnell, dauert noch ein bisschen.
Ja, aber vielleicht nicht mehr so lang. Nicht zu meiner Lebenszeit.
Ich glaube auch nicht. Da fehlt schon noch ein bisschen was.
Aber so in Richtung Intelligent Assistant scheint schon eine ganze Menge zu passieren.
Wann war diese Geschichte mit dem Watson-Computer von IBM, der bei diesem News-Spiel da irgendwie auch gewonnen hat, bei diesem Jeopardy oder was es da war, der wirklich Tausende von Terabyte an Daten hat und alle möglichen Enzyklopedien durchgeforsert hat und irgendwie alles weiß und alles suchen kann auf die Schnelle und dann Fragen beantwortet. Ich meine, dahin wird es gehen. Diese Technik, die wird immer mehr für Zuhause kommen und immer schneller.
2011 war das mit dem...
Ja, es ist schon wieder vier Jahre her. Da kannst du dir ja vorstellen, wenn das zehn Jahre dauert, bis man so ein Power irgendwie vielleicht jetzt nicht zu Hause hat, bis man das ganz oft in einem Rechenzentrum stehen haben kann und nicht nur einmalig so eine teure Kiste ist. Und dann geht das ab.
Vor allem wohl durch die Vernetzung mit solchen Systemen wie Wolfram Alpha hast du halt diese ganze Intelligenz da und jetzt musst du sozusagen nur noch für das User-Interface sorgen und das entsprechende Device, über das du dieses User-Interface deliverst, wo ich halt schon auch die Apple Watch eigentlich so als den Primärkandidaten sehe.
Unseren Residenten-Watch-Spezialisten ja nicht da, weder den geliehenden, noch auch unser Stammpersonal.
Ja, haben wir nicht. Aber demnächst kann man die Uhr wohl auch offiziell mal so kaufen einfach. Dann werde ich das dann auch mal tun. Jaja, ich bin da schon länger überzeugt, dass sie mir eine holen will.
Ich habe es gar nicht mehr verfolgt. Gab es da eigentlich noch mal ein Update vom Pfarrstuhlschacht?
Ja, er hat sie gefunden, sie war gesplittet und hat wahrscheinlich mit dieser unglaublichen Geschichte den Genius an der Apple-Bahn Verzückung und Sympathie Überschuss gebracht und es wurde angenommen zur Reparatur.
Also Apples offizielle Policy ist, wenn ein Ding in zwei Teile zerbrochen ist, dann ist das dein Problem. Aber wie gesagt, Roddy hat seinen Charme spielen lassen und der Genius hat auch gemeint, das kann gar nicht sein, neunter Stock, da muss so ein Ding da überleben. War er wohl eine ganze Weile im Backoffice, hat er Diskussionen mit seinem Manager gesprochen, dann hat der Genius das doch weggeschickt, die Uhr.
Ja, musst halt mal Roddy im Internet doch mal denken.
Ja, ich verfolge, also... Doch, natürlich verfolge ich Roddy schon lange, aber ich komme tatsächlich so selten zum Lesen im Moment.
Ernsthaft?
Bist du etwa ein Fan-Girl von unserer Sendung?
Die Antwort lautet doch diese Frage, nein.
Kommentiert mit Hihi, das Gesicht der Frau im Apple Store, alleine war das Geld wert. Ja, die ist richtig kaputt.
Aber da kann man wenigstens reingucken.
Der Unterteil sieht doch noch ganz cool aus. Nur das oben ist so ein bisschen Matsch.
Genau, sich reden müsste doch noch gehen.
Das war ja jetzt auch so eine Billo-Watch. Das war ja hier die Discount-Variante.
Roddy twittert übrigens am 16.06. Apple hat tatsächlich eine neue Uhr gegeben.
Let's learn, Scheißaufzüge.
Es war auch echt interessant, dass noch jemand ganz anderes irgendwie auch in San Francisco kurz vorher twitterte, dass dieser Spalt zwischen Aufzug und Ebene doch sehr viel breiter sei, als man das so bei uns gewohnt sei. Und dann die Geschichte, dass so eine Uhr darunter fallen...
Also das Hausverklagt, dieser Spalt ist zu breit, das entspricht nicht...
Der normalen... Der normal gewohnten Norm in...
Er hätte eigentlich, was er eigentlich hätte machen müssen, um hier wirklich einen Beitrag zu leisten und um seinen Blog-Artikel auch around the world zu machen.
Gleiche Dissekten, so wie...
Nein, du kaufst danach eine Apple Watch mit Safir-Glas.
Und schmeißt den nochmal runter.
Ja, dann geht die auch so kaputt.
Ja, nee. Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Doch, weil Safir ist zwar scheiße hart, aber sehr spröde und geht eigentlich noch schneller kaputt.
Wenn du genügend umfasst.
Du hast schon gesehen.
Kann man eigentlich mal ausrechnen, wann wiegt so ein Ding?
Hast du diese Videos gesehen, wo die irgendwie versucht haben, dieses Safir-Glas irgendwie auch nur......kratzen oder kaputt zu machen? Die haben da mit einem Hammer drauf geschlagen.
Ach, das sind alles Fake-Videos. Gib mir so ein Ding, ich mach dir das kaputt.
Die einzig wichtige Frage ist......Bohrer. Will it blend?
Haben doch bestimmt schon wieder Spacken rausgefallen.
Das gab's bestimmt schon, ja ja. Das gab's schon. So, jetzt haben wir uns eigentlich schon wieder von der AI ein bisschen entfernt. Also ich denke halt, dass diese Apple Watch auf jeden Fall so mit Siri auf einmal, da macht das irgendwie auf einmal total Sinn.
Ich weiß nicht, ich frag mich halt an der Stelle, wie wollen sie das weiterentwickeln? Insofern, in dem Sinne, dass sie ja die ganze Zeit sagen, sie werden das halt oder sie haben es halt nicht in der Cloud. Also das, was man da an dieses Kontext basierte, ist ja von Apple-Seite eigentlich da der Standpunkt, dass sie das nicht in die Cloud geben und wegen Privacy. Und das, um sich natürlich auch von Google abzugrenzen, die mit Now on Tap eine ganz andere Schiene fahren. Aber die Frage ist, wie soll das weitergehen? Also wenn dann die kontextbasierten Dinge immer nur daraus kommen, was du mit deinem Telefon machst. Ich meine, die Frage haben sich jetzt auch andere schon gestellt. Aber was passiert, wenn du dein Telefon wechselst? Nein, also was passiert mit dem, was du eigentlich dann antrainiert hast?
Also so ein Backup einspielen ist ein wesentlicher...
Wenn sie sagen, sie speichern das nicht auf deinen Namen, dann machen sie es ja trotzdem über einen Hash über deinen Namen oder irgendwie so.
Also das wäre natürlich eine Möglichkeit, aber sie werden natürlich irgendwie in diesem ganzen kontextbasierten Bereich immer hinter Google zurückhängen müssen, einfach weil Google da einfach eine sehr viel längere und sehr viel größere Datenbasis hat, aus der sie lernen können. Also ich weiß halt nicht, ob das, also ja, ich finde das schon ganz cool und ich frage mich halt, ich weiß noch nicht, ob ich es benutzen werde.
Willst du denn eine Uhr kaufen?
Ja.
Aber hast du auch noch nicht gemacht.
Nee.
Warum?
Ich spare noch fürs Goldmodell.
Ich spare noch fürs Goldmodell. Nee, ich muss erst mal andere Investitionen tätigen.
Also jetzt wegen Geld hast du es noch nicht gemacht. Und nicht wegen du bist hier nicht sicher oder du weißt noch nicht, welches Band du nimmst.
Nee, ich bin in den letzten paar Jahren zu oft umgezogen. Das hält dann immer noch so ein bisschen nach.
Ja, naja, ich bin mir auch noch nicht so ganz so sicher, ob ich irgendwie mir so eine Billo-Uhr hole oder gleich.
Also ich hatte tatsächlich einer am Arm und hab eigentlich gedacht, ich würde mir wenn das große Modell kaufen, hatte sie aber am Handgelenk und hab gesehen, nee, also das kleine ist bei mir eigentlich super und ich würde wahrscheinlich sogar beim Billo-Modell bleiben mit weißem Sportarmband.
Wirklich? Also das schlägt ja bei mir nicht so ein mit dem Weiß.
Der richtige Apple-Fanboy trägt Weiß.
Nur weil Tim Cook das macht?
Nee, weil er weiß ist.
Schade, dass das ein Audi-Podcast. Ist.
Das war schon beeindruckend.
Ja, wir sollten so kleine Audio-Awards haben, wo man immer auf eine Tasse drücken kann und dann so...
Warum haben wir eigentlich nicht alle längste Soundboards?
Weil ich gerade zu wenig Zeit in diesem Studio verbringen kann. Ja, Flash, ich weiß.
Stimmt, wir haben noch eine Stunde.
Ja, sonst reicht es schon wieder nicht.
Das wäre ja schlimm, dass wir uns nächste Woche wieder treffen.
Wir würden am Anfang immer ganz viel und am Ende dann geben wir mal Sport und dann ist alles immer ein bisschen kurz.
Also wir beenden die AI-Diskussion.
Für eine Stunde reicht es noch.
Für eine Stunde oder für eine Viertelstunde?
Für eine Stunde. Ja, ich habe letztens zehnmal gesagt, irgendwie Berlin, nein, das ist nicht ein Dialekt, das ist eine Einstellung. Also...
Das ist keine Einstellung, das ist eine Verfassung.
Ein Zustand. Ich nehme es gerne hier.
Nee, mach mal hier genauso wie Dash, du fängst mit Bitcode an und dann können wir weiter zu SSDs.
Du musst noch aufholen, von letzter Sendung Huckel jetzt.
Vor allen Dingen, da stehen auch noch so häufig steht da Huckel dran. Der Huckel hat eigentlich jetzt die ganze nächste Sendung auch noch mal.
Aber es sind kleine Sachen.
Die Huckel Special Sendung.
Ja, das ist Huckel Special.
Das sind ja auch alles kleine Sachen.
Bitcode ist nur ein kurzer Gedanke, weil das so ein bisschen aufkam.
Aber hatten wir eigentlich auch in der letzten Sendung ganz schön gut dran, das Ding.
Hatten wir schon, ganz genau.
Aber Tim hat weitergedacht.
Andere Leute haben auch weitergedacht. Ich habe dann den Artikel gelesen und gebe jetzt ihren Gedankengang als meinen aus. Ja, ich weiß gar nicht so ganz genau, was ich sagen wollte. Aber es ist natürlich ein Aspekt, den wir nicht besprochen haben, was ist, wenn das mit dem Bitcode so weitergeht? Also ich habe zumindest mittlerweile unsere Vermutung bestätigt gesehen, dass es sich halt tatsächlich, was sollte es auch anderes sein, LLVM Intermediate Code ist, das ist klar.
Haben wir aber auch gesagt.
Haben wir auch alles gesagt.
Jetzt nicht mal einen Artikel zu lesen.
Dass wir da Recht gehabt haben. Man muss ja auch, wenn wir mal Recht gehabt haben, muss man das ja auch mal sagen dürfen, oder? Wo wir sonst immer daneben liegen. Und bloß haben wir so ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, dass, wie Apple das ja auch selber ausgedrückt hat, dass es ja sozusagen die Möglichkeit gibt, dass, wenn sie einen neuen Prozessor rausgibt, dass sie dann Optimierungen auch nachträglich machen.
Hatten wir auch in der letzten Sendung nicht nur, dass sie einen neuen Prozess haben, sondern einen anderen, nämlich einen Arm. Hatten wir erwähnt. Ich habe gesagt, wenn ein neues MacBook Air dann mal mitten im Arm kommt, dass sie nur Schnips machen und Tausende von Apps schon fertig sind.
Da muss ich wohl gerade was Wichtiges getan haben. Was? Nö, weiß ich nicht. Also ich bin mir jetzt über eine breitere Diskussion nicht mehr so ganz im Klaren, ob wir die wirklich gehabt haben. Aber es würde ja auch bedeuten, dass wenn überhaupt erst mal alle Apps vorliegen in Bitcode, also man denke sich, sie würden das halt jetzt auch im Mac App Store einführen, wird sicherlich nächstes Jahr soweit sein. Nehme ich mal an.
Dieses Jahr noch, denke ich.
Haben sie aber jetzt nicht angekündigt. Also dann wird es nicht im nächsten halben Jahr passieren.
Haben sie nicht gesagt, das ist so ein Teil von Xcode 7, OS 10, 11 und iOS 9 oder irgendwie so?
Ja, iOS 9 haben sie erwähnt, aber es bezog sich ausschließlich auf den iOS App Store. Und nicht auf den Mac App Store. Und ich könnte mir halt durchaus vorstellen, dass sie da im nächsten Jahr nachziehen. Was wiederum bedeutet, dass sie ab dann die Möglichkeit haben, all die ganzen Apps quasi für welche Plattform auch immer zu compilen. Sodass, wenn sie wirklich in der Zukunft irgendwann mal einen Wechsel machen wollen würden, zumindest schon mal eine extreme reale Codebase hätten, mit der sie das dann auch testen können.
Vielleicht hilft das sogar beim CPU-Designen.
Darauf wollte ich eigentlich auch hinaus, dass das unabhängig davon, was sie jetzt tatsächlich machen, dass sie ja schon im Vorfeld sehen können, wie diese Apps performen, wenn sie voll optimiert sind. Beziehungsweise sie können ihre Optimierung auch real world auf die tatsächlich existierenden gerade publizierten Apps ausdehnen. Das ist natürlich auch schon eine coole Sache. Und wenn man es noch mal weiterdenkt, kann man sich auch schon wieder fast fragen, was ist, wenn Software generell nur noch irgendwie in diesem Intermediate-Code zum Download bereitstellt und jeder compiles sich sozusagen die Dinger.
Meinst du, dass Apple das nicht mehr macht, sondern ich mir den Bytecode runterlade und das auf meinem Rechner mache?
Ja, also man könnte ja sozusagen Software im Bytecode bereitstellen.
Ja, aber das macht ja nicht so wirklich Sinn, wenn Apple irgendwie 20-mal für ihre 20 Geräte compilert. Also dann reicht es doch, wenn die das 20-mal machen, dann müssen das ja nicht 20 oder 200 Millionen Leute auch noch machen. Deren Hardware ist ja übersichtlich. Für Microsoft wäre das interessant, weil die wissen nicht, was da draußen für Hardware ist, wo irgendwie Windows draufläuft, weil das wissen die einfach nicht mehr. Und für die wäre das vielleicht ganz cool.
Eine andere Sache ist, dass sie auch dann sozusagen auch gar nicht mehr die Details über ihre Prozessoren groß herausgeben müssen, weil es zwingt sie ja noch nicht mal jemand überhaupt den Code Generator zu publizieren.
Ja, und den Compiler auch nicht. Das heißt, sie könnten immer so einen El Chippo Compiler rausgeben und die ganz coolen Sachen aber für sich behalten.
Der Compiler ist halt LL, also ist halt der C-Lang.
Der Optimierer halt, den könnten...
Genau, das heißt, jeder macht irgendwie das und dann haben sie da irgendwie ihren Voodoo für ihren Wunderprozessor.
Aber auch, dass für den Developer so toll ist, wenn Apple dann irgendwas rumoptimiert und wenn dein Timing ist dann irgendwie, dann ist zwar das eine zehnmal schneller, was dir aber eigentlich egal ist, weil das andere muss schnell sein und das ist dann aber 10% langsamer und dann hast du die Arschkarte.
Ja, du hast ja recht. Man muss ja irgendwie auf seiner eigenen Büchse auch noch arbeiten können. Achso, in dem Zusammenhang vielleicht noch ganz interessant, das haben wir aber glaube ich so nicht erwähnt. Wer hat darüber gesprochen, dass sich dieses Developer-Programm ändert? Dass es nur noch eins gibt?
Das ist jetzt nur noch ein, wie sagt man, ein so ein Developer-Gizent.
Einer, der alle OSs gibt. Und was ich aber ähm äh übersehen hatte, ist, dass das neue Xcode 7 jetzt keinerlei Developer-Account mehr vorsieht, um selber Apps auf deinem Device zu deployen.
Haben wir aber auch letztes Mal gesagt.
Ehrlich? Auch, dass es irgendwie ein Zeitlimit gibt dafür? Na ja, wenn du die Apps so machst, dass sie dann nur 30 Tage laufen, das war irgendwie so ein Gerücht, das ich noch aufgeschnappt habe. Na ja gut, ich überspringe das jetzt einfach mal. Wenn wir das sowieso schon alles diskutiert haben, weiß ich gar nicht, worüber ich überhaupt noch rede. Machen wir weiter.
Aber hier gibt es noch, hier hat einer im, was kann man nochmal kurz erwähnen, da zitiert jemand, was? Dass jemand den Chris Lettner gefragt hat, ob es, wo ist die Frage, ob das schon eine neue CPU-Architektur irgendwie ankündigt, dass sie mit diesem Bytecode arbeiten und der meint, man soll mehr so dran denken, dass sie eine neue Instruktion, also eine Multiply Instruction mit einführen, weil wenn man schon Bitcode hat, also diesen Bytecode würde ich den jetzt mal jetzt nennen, diesen Intermediate Format, dass man schon sehr architekturnah ist, wahrscheinlich wegen 32 und 64 Bit, das ist alles schon Parameter, also RAM, Registeranzahl, das ist ja alles schon relativ fest genagelt und deswegen ist das schon zu spät. Aber vielleicht ist das ja auch schon der nächste Schritt. Aber es heißt, dass es erst mal nicht so aussieht, als wenn sie nach Armen schnell machen.
Wie die jeweiligen CPU-Spezialisierungen, die es ja immer noch gibt, kann man dann machen, kann man dann optimieren.
Ist ja für Apple auch schon wertvoll. Die Huckel hat schon so viel heute.
Das ist die Huckel-Sendung.
Denn es hat letztes Mal nämlich auch sehr wenig gesagt.
Ich erinnere mich da auch noch dran. Dennis durfte letztes Mal nicht Bitcoin.
Aber ich dachte, wenn die Zensurbehörde da ist, dann grätscht sie mal zwischendurch.
Rein. Aber wir sind doch jetzt hier im Programming.
Also ich würde sagen, stattgegeben.
Eine interessante Menge von parallelen Buchstaben.
Bei Bitcoin gibt es eine neue Version demnächst. Da gibt es gerade einen Release-Kandidaten, Version 2, der kam heute raus. Das ist die Version 0.11. Und da gibt es ein interessantes Feature. Das bisherige Problem war ja immer, dass die Leute keinen, wie sagt man, keinen vollen Node zu Hause fahren möchten. Also das ist das, wenn der komplette Bitcoin die ganze Zeit rennt und diese 30 GB, die es inzwischen sind auf der Platte... Oder mehr noch und die ganze Zeit halt mit Außenconnections mit anderen Bitcoins aufnimmt und man die Transaction so hin und her schiebt und so, was das eigentliche Bitcoin-Netzwerk ja ausmacht. Also darum geht es ja. Und da gibt es bei der Version 0.11 ein neues, was heißt ein Feature, aber eine neue... ja doch.
Die ist jetzt draußen?
Nein, die ist in Release Candidates 2. Also man ist noch experimentell. Also die normalen Leute sollten schon noch abwarten, bis die richtige draußen ist. Aber da gibt es ein Feature, das heißt Pruning. Und das sorgt dafür, dass alles, was nicht mehr gebraucht wird von diesen 30 GB, wird weggeschmissen. Also stell dir vor, der Ole Satoshi 2009 hat ja da Bitcoins generiert ohne Ende. Und irgendeiner hat ja auch die 10.000 Bitcoins generiert, womit er sich diese eine Pizza gekauft hat oder zwei Pizzen bezahlt hat, diese berühmte erste große Transaktion. Und dann wandern die Bitcoins ja von einer Adresse zu einer anderen, weil er hat sie ja weitergeschoben. Und dann sind die auf der originalen Adresse nicht mehr drauf. So und in diesen 30 GB steht aber der ganze Weg, wo diese Bitcoins lang gewandert sind, der steht sozusagen in diesen 30 GB. Und das könnte man da irgendwie zurückverfolgen. Und aber eigentlich ist, wenn man jetzt nicht so alle Features braucht, dann bräuchte man nicht diesen ganzen Weg von diesen Bitcoins, sondern man könnte alles, wo die Bitcoins mal entstanden sind, aber wo die gar nicht mehr sind, das könnte man wegschmeißen, also prunen, wegschmeißen.
Wenn sie vollständig verschwunden sind.
Wenn sie vollständig verschwunden sind. Und dann werden deine 30 GB halt kleiner. Und diese Version 11, die fängt damit an, dass sie schon Sachen wegschmeißt, die nicht mehr gebraucht werden und aus Verifizierungsgründen für den Neustart von Bitcoin, der checkt immer die letzten 288 Blöcke. Also ich glaube, das sind die letzten zwei Tage an Blöcken, die entstanden sind. Die behält er sich immer drin, damit er da noch so Sachen checken kann, dass deine Blockchain noch valide ist und so. Aber alles Ältere, wenn das irgendwie weitergewandert ist und das ist nicht mehr da, dann wird es weggeschmissen und damit legen die gerade los. Die sind aber noch nicht so komplett fertig damit. Das wird dann noch reichlich mehr kommen, weil mit diesem Pruning-Mode kann man auch keine Wallet mehr haben. Das heißt, man kann den nicht mehr eigentlich als Bitcoin benutzen, sondern man kann ihn nur noch als ein Node nutzen, der das Netzwerk unterstützt, in dem man halt Transactions weiter hin und her schiebt. Und diese Version, die dann kommt, die wird auch keine Blöcke hin und her schieben können, weil Blöcke werden ja auch zwischen den Nodes ausgetauscht, wenn einer einen neuen Block findet. Das kann so eine Version zurzeit auch noch nicht, das wird aber kommen. Das ist sozusagen jetzt der Anfang.
Aber was heißt, man kann da keine Wallet mehr drin führen?
Haben die gerade noch nicht. Ich kann das nicht genau erklären, warum das nicht geht. Wahrscheinlich, weil halt so ein...
Aber das ist doch jetzt ein Kernfeature verdämpft von dem Programm oder redest du jetzt wieder von was anderem?
Das ist eigentlich natürlich das Kernfeature von Bitcoins, aber man kann ja das Bitcoin-Netzwerk auch unterstützen, indem man halt nur eine Node laufen lässt, die halt einfach mithilft, Transaktionen von A nach B zu schieben oder einfach mehrere Clients miteinander zu connecten, dass eine Transaktion schneller im gesamten Netzwerk rum ist. Genau. Und der nächste Punkt ist, dass grundsätzlich die Bitcoin-Community sagt gerade, sie haben zu wenig Nodes, weil eigentlich soll es ja eine dezentrale Sache sein. Darauf basiert ja die ganze Sache mit den Bitcoins. Und es gibt aber zu wenig Nodes und deswegen heißt es, es sollen mehr Nodes kommen. Deswegen arbeiten wir auch mit diesem Pruning, damit es für die Leute leichter ist, als so ein Node zu haben, dass es nicht so viel Platz auf der Platte kostet und dir deine SSD über Jahre kaputt macht, weil die ganze Zeit wird da rumgeschrieben und so. Und deswegen ist mein Aufruf auch an Leute, die sowieso irgendwo einen Rechner haben, der nicht allzu viel zu tun hat. Startet irgendwie einfach so ein Bitcoin-Demon, lasst ihn voll laufen. Auch noch ohne Pruning, das ist gar nicht so wichtig. Da würde ich erst abwarten, bis das irgendwie noch ein bisschen besser geworden ist. Und dann gibt es mehr Nodes da draußen. Das ist irgendwie wichtig. Und es ist nicht so schwer. Es kann so ein Raspberry 2 mit seinen vier Cores, der sollte das auch können. Er ist vielleicht nicht der Schnellste, aber es hilft schon mal. Dann noch eine Bitcoin-Geschichte ist, einer der ältesten Bitcoin-Pools, die es gibt, und zwar BTC-Guild. Der macht zum 30.06. irgendwie seine Pforten dicht. Aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Entweder, ich glaube, das lohnt sich nicht mehr, aber er sagt, es hat mit dieser New Yorker-Bit-License zu tun, dass man da irgendwie zu viel Daten irgendwie rausrücken muss. Ich weiß nicht so genau, was der eigentliche Grund ist, aber das wird so gemunkelt. Jedenfalls, wenn der dichtmacht und ihren neuen Pool braucht, meiner läuft noch. btcmp.com ist auch reichlich schneller geworden. Ich habe da jetzt anstatt Python-Code im Backend ist da jetzt das in C. Das ist von dem gleichen Typen geschrieben, der CG Miner geschrieben hat. Ich habe das mal auf FreeBSD portiert und auch noch an manchen Stellen bis um das, keine Ahnung, 40 oder 100-fache beschleunigt. Also so kleine Ecken intern, die aber schon noch wichtig sind. Und läuft jetzt super seit einem Monat. Also ihr könnt alle draufballern und so. Der hält alles aus. Der ist irgendwie skaliert ohne Ende. Das sind irgendwie 15 Threads oder so. Der kann was wegstecken. Also ich würde behaupten, der steckt mehr weg als bei dem eigentlichen Programmierer, der das gemacht hat, weil ich es so schön optimiert habe. Und ja, das tut jetzt alles super. Könnt da draufballern, wenn ihr wollt. Mit wie viel Gigabits oder Gigahashes auch immer. Ja, genau, gib mir alles.
Außer Tiernahrung.
Das war's?
Bei Bitcoin schon, ja. Ja, doch.
Großes ist wieder ein bisschen gestiegen.
Ja, genau, das habe ich heute auch festgestellt. Das geht gerade so ein bisschen aufwärts, seit gestern oder so. Das war immer so bei 204, es ist rumgeeiert. Und jetzt ist es bei 217 jetzt bei mir wieder. Also bei 224 war er aber auch schon. Also er ist auf jeden Fall am Steigen, so langsam, aber stetig. Mal gucken, zwei Tage.
Er wird gleich wieder viel reicher. Er muss noch ein bisschen steigen, damit wir uns alle unser Schloss in der Schweiz kaufen können von unseren zehn Bitcoins.
Was willst du mit dem Schloss?
Disney.
In der Schweiz. Skifahren?
Keine Ahnung, Internet installieren, dann wieder verkaufen.
Ja, und zwar habe ich auch wieder von Amtswegen, also beruflich quasi, nicht mal damit auseinandersetzen müssen, wie man wohl so Dinge simuliert. Und dann gibt es also Sportereignisse in dem weitesten Sinne, sage ich mal. Und da gibt es so die naive, intuitive Variante, dass man sich natürlich ein Simulator schreibt, so schön, so Tick-by-Tick. Also wenn Objekt des Sports gerade in Feld X ist, dann würfeln wir mal und gucken, was jetzt als nächstes mit dem passiert und dann baut man sich...
Du nimmst ja nicht einfach Historie, die es schon gibt.
Na ja, halt mal, holt eure Horses. Also das ist so der naive Ansatz und dann habe ich mal so ein bisschen rumgegoogelt und dann stellt sich raus, gibt es natürlich schon Papers dafür, die ganze Premier-League- Saisons, zum Beispiel Fußball, vorsimulierenden Weltmeisterschaften, was auch immer, und rein probabilistisch quasi auf historischen Daten basierend. Und dann wollte ich damit mal rumspielen, um sozusagen so Proof of Concept mäßig zu zeigen, ja Leute, pass mal auf, also wir würfeln jetzt vielleicht nicht 500 Mal, sondern nur einmal und machen den Code nicht dreieinhalb Millisekunden langsam, sondern vielleicht im Bereich von drei Mikrosekunden. Und dann dachte ich, ja, scheiße, aber wie macht man das jetzt? Weil das Stichwort, was da fällt, sind Poisson-Verteilungen für die Freunde der Statistik und Probabilistik. Der heißt Fisch. Ja, kann sein. Fischverteilung. Poisson-Verteilung. Es gibt auch ein schönes Paper, was ich euch mal hier zum Thema einfach in den Chat werfe, wer sich dafür interessiert. Der kann das ja mal ein bisschen anlesen. Auf jeden Fall bin ich dann auf der Suche gewesen, wie kann man das denn jetzt mal machen, und dachte halt so in meiner standard Programmiersprache Ruby, dachte ich, okay, guckste mal. Das Problem ist bei dieser Poisson-Verteilung, wenn man das richtig machen will, für kleine Werte kann man das naiv implementieren und dann reicht auch die Geschwindigkeit und für größere Werte dauert es dann langsam. Also wird es immer langsamer mit der naiven Implementierung. Und dann dachte ich, okay, googelste mal ein bisschen, stell dich raus, wie so oft gibt es Papers aus den 70ern, wo so ein paar Typen aus Kiel, glaube ich sogar, einmal das so runter implementiert haben für kleine und große Werte und das auch noch immer auf dem Abakus implementiert Bestand hat. Und das habe ich so gefunden, also das habe ich gefunden und dann habe ich weiter gegoogelt und eins dieser Suchergebnisse sagte mir auch, dass in der Programmiersprache Rrrrr, genau dieser Algorithmus, also dieses Paper, nach implementiert ist. Und dann dachte ich mir, ja, dieses Rrrr, das habe ich ja schon oft gehört, ne. Das ist halt, wie soll man das so, so eine Data, Data Analysis, Statistik, Mathe-Programmiersprache. Also es ist halt schon eine Programmiersprache, aber hat so ein paar Spezial-Features. Zum Beispiel Matrizen-Multiplikation ist halt der Standard, ja. Also alle Operationen, Multiplikation, Addition, etc., pp. Kannst halt immer Listen oder, also Vektoren aller Dimensionen quasi reinschmeißen und miteinander verschmelzen. Aller Dimension natürlich nicht, aber mehrere. Was halt einfach so dieses Fressen von Daten und Verhackstücken einfach sehr schön macht, weil es dir einfach diverse genästete Vorschleifen erspart, um durch deine normalen Aries halt so durchzutigern. Naja und dann diese Porsoir-Verteilung zum Beispiel speziell, die ist halt auch in C implementiert, das heißt es ratten schnell und dann habe ich einfach mal so, habe ich mir gedacht, ok pass auf, ich mach jetzt mal hier 10 Millionen Würfellein ja und guck einfach mal, wie schnell das so geht mit meinem Ruby und so und auch mit der naiven Implementierung und das dauert und der Chor ist busy und ja dann kommt auch was bei raus.
Hätte ich gedacht, du machst das in R lang.
Ja, habe ich danach auch gemacht. Genau, in R ist das halt, du kannst halt sofort sagen, mach mir mal 10 Millionen Würfelungen, steck das mal in eine Poisson-Verteilung, steck das mal in den Histogramm und plotte das Histogramm und dir geht sofort so ein Quarz-View auf mit dem Diagramm und es geht halt so, bumm, zack, return. Also es ist wirklich so für so Mathe- und Data-Crunching extrem performant. Ich habe auch mal zum Spaß nur das CSV generiert, für so eine Million Würfellein und das in R reingeladen und genau das Gleiche gemacht und das ist sofort, BAM, Ergebnis, Graph, Plot, super.
Ich habe bisher immer nur in Verbindung mit Matlab gehört, also beides dann entweder gegeneinander oder zumindest als Äquivalent oder das eine kann mehr, das andere kann weniger.
Naja, also wenn man das jetzt hier so mit Homebrew oder so installieren würde, dann kriegt man halt einfach das Executable, die Interactive Shell. Das ist halt geil, du tippst einfach nur ein und dann kommt dann das Shell hoch und das geile ist halt, dieses R hat einfach eine saugeile Inline Help, also du kannst jederzeit irgendwie nach suchen, nach Dingen, zum Beispiel wenn du nur nach random suchst, da gibt es irgendwie fünf verschiedene Implementierungen für random number generators und du kannst ja auch noch aussuchen, verschiedene Seeding-Verfahren und so weiter. Also es ist wirklich, wer mal richtig so Mathe machen will und Statistik und auswerten, ist geil. Kann ich sehr empfehlen und ich habe mir auch zwei Bücher gekauft, das eine von O'Reilly oder beziehungsweise von der Firma kaufen lassen, eins von O'Reilly und eins von Manning und ich glaube, das von Manning kann ich eher empfehlen, wer mal damit anfangen will, so sich auch auseinanderzusetzen. Also es ist wirklich saukool, weil jeder, der mal einen CSV vor die Nase gehalten bekommt mit vielen Daten drin und mal plotten will und Histogramme malen und so, das ist, wenn man das von Hand programmiert, scheiß. Also es macht keinen Spaß. Und da sagst du einfach Plot-Klammer auf, Hist-Klammer auf, ziehst dir die Daten da rein und fertig. Und es ist in weniger als einer Sekunde, also es ist Bum-Zack-Return, ist das da. So und jetzt, wer jetzt noch wissen will, also ich hab diese Poisson-Verteilung, diesen Algorithmus, der in C war, ich hab mir halt von R die C-Files für diese Poisson-Verteilung reingezogen. Und das ist echt C-Code. Also ich bin ja nicht so ein advanceder C-Coder, aber der hat mich mit Gotoo und so, der hat mich in verschiedene Box-Hörner gejagt, oder If-Statements, die nach einer Zeile mit einem Semikolon beendet werden, wo man da nicht weiß, wo der Blog zu Ende ist, weil man immer auf die Klammer wartet. Auf jeden Fall...
Kann ja auch ohne Klammer sein, wenn da ein Semikolon hinten ist.
Ja, genau, genau.
Dann ist der gleich dahinter, der Contest kann.
Genau, ganz genau.
Ja, aber eigentlich uncool, finde ich jedenfalls.
Ja, das ist halt Code, wie gesagt, ist halt schon ein bisschen älter. Aber ich hab das tatsächlich in Erlang mal nachimplementiert und auch so ein, zwei andere statistische Funktionen. Wer sich dafür interessiert, der kann auf dieses Repository im Chat klicken, beziehungsweise in den Show Notes und sich der Poisson-Verteilung in performantester Implementierung erfreuen. Der C-Code ist immer noch schneller, aber das Erlang kommt auch schon ganz gut mit, muss ich sagen. So, und jetzt für Leute, den R zu sperrig ist, wie es ja auch Leute gibt, den Erlang vielleicht syntaktisch erstmal zu sperrig ist. Es gibt irgendwie ein Projekt, hat mir ein Kollege gesagt, das heißt SciPy, weil in der wissenschaftlichen Community ist ja Python auch irgendwie hoch im Kurs. Und SciPy ist im Prinzip so ein Projekt, wo es darum geht, auch so ganz viele mathematische, wie sagt man, Werkzeuge einfach bereitzustellen. Und jetzt habe ich leider das Projekt vergessen, was richtig geil ist, es gibt nämlich eine Web-Oberfläche, wo du so Worksheets hast, wo du deine Formeln und deine Analysen und auch deine Data-Sources so speichern kannst und zusammen kompilieren kannst. Und das rendert dir dann halt die Graphen auch gleich im Web und du kannst das auch wiederholen, kannst das an SQL-Datenbanken hängen und so weiter und so fort. Aber da gibt es zwar auch so IDE's dafür und es kann im Prinzip das gleiche und wahrscheinlich auch noch ein bisschen mehr, aber dieses SciPy und dieses andere Projekt, das Name ich jetzt gerade vergessen habe, dieses Web-Frontend, damit kann man halt vielleicht Leuten, die so im Pyson eh schon zu Hause sind, auch nochmal die Möglichkeit geben, so ein bisschen matte Sport zu machen. Ich weiß nicht, ob die auch bestimmte Sachen in C implementieren, um so die Performance zu kriegen, die vielleicht R in vielen Fällen hat, aber ist auf jeden Fall noch eine Alternative. Was mich bei R tatsächlich wirklich beeindruckt hat, ist so, wie ernst und gewissenhaft die bestimmte Sachen implementiert haben. Also wenn du einfach so nach random suchst und mal gucken willst, was habt ihr denn hier so für random, also dann gibt es erstmal random-Verteilung verschiedene, exponentielle, normale, und was auch immer. Und dann halt so eine Sektion, welchen random Number Generator willst du denn? Der ist nach Paper XY implementiert, der ist hier das Box-Muller-Modell, der ist halt das und das. Und dann, oh ich habe die Auswahl, erstmal Wikipedia lesen, welchen ich denn eigentlich haben will.
Welchen Zufall hätten sie denn gerne?
Ja, genau. Nee, also fand ich auf jeden Fall ganz gut und jeder, der wirklich anfängt Vorschleifen zu nesten, um einen CSV zu parsen, um dann am Ende einen Graf in Excel daraus zu plotten, der macht was falsch und sollte sich mit AR beschäftigen. War auf jeden Fall mal echt so ein geiler Programmiersport, mal wieder so erstens zu gucken, was an dem R passiert, dann das C zu lesen, wo ich ja kein C-Coder bin, und das dann in R lang, also von imperativ in funktional zu übersetzen. Das war echt, das war richtig geil, das Kopfkino, also Donner Schock, da hab ich eine Weide gestrickt. Also so ein Go-To in funktional korrekt nachzuimplementieren, war wirklich eine Challenge. Aber das Schöne dann wiederum, ich hab halt in beiden immer die CSVs rausgeplottet, also für verschiedenste Werte, Dimensionen und hab das dann halt mit R wieder geplottet, um dann die C-Implementierung gegen die R-Lang-Implementierung zu testen und dann kam halt da das Gleiche irgendwann raus.
Ich finde, du hast da einen ziemlich netten Job, also es klingt zumindestens. Ja, das ist nicht so, ja, mach mal die Webseite, da ist ein Button lila, mach den mal blau.
Deswegen halt ich es auch so lange aus, weil zwischendurch immer mal so Themen gibt, wo man auch mal forschen kann. Und ich jetzt mal noch so eine Ansage, die ich den jungen Programmierern unter euch hören mitgeben möchte.
Ich glaube, ich weiß, was jetzt kommt.
Weil ganz, also ich meine, ich war da auch so, weil ich war ja früher Gestalter und als ich hier so mit Programmieren angefangen habe, war ich ja auch erstmal hier Ruby on Rails Blog in 15 Minuten, Copy Paste, klicklackluck, los geht's. Ist ja auch gut zum Anfang, also so geht es ja los. Aber ganz oft, wenn ihr irgendwie so ein Problem habt und es ist so ein Problem, wo man so denkt, hm, fieses Problem. Nochmal denkt, hat bestimmt auch schon mal jemand anderes gehabt. Dann lohnt es sich wirklich eine halbe Stunde oder einen halben Tag noch mal zu googeln, ob es nicht irgendein Paper aus den 70ern und 80ern gibt, wo einer das einfach schon komplett mit Soße und Schaf in Hochperformant implementiert hat und tausendmal besser als alles, was ihr jemals euch ausdenken hätte können.
Die mussten damals auch Hochperformant implementieren, damit es irgendwann mal fertig wurde.
Genau, das geile in diesem Paper zu der Poisson-Verteilungselementierung ist auch so, dann beschreiben sie auf ihrem Siemens, was auch immer, Oldschool-Schrank, großen Computer und dann haben sie auch getestet, ob jetzt die Assembler-Implementierung, die sie gemacht haben, irgendwie schneller ist, als das, was sie in C geschrieben haben und Fortran auch nochmal und dann haben sie auch eine Implementierung gemacht und meinten halt so, ja die verbraucht halt keinen, also das C ist genauso schnell wie der Assembler und verbraucht nicht mehr RAM, also nehmt einfach C und ist halt so schön auf so einem...
Deswegen nennen wir C liebevoll immer noch unseren Makro-Assembler.
Aber wirklich ernsthaft, ich hab bei VUGA hatten wir schon ein, zwei Probleme oder drei, vier, wo die erste naive Idee war, ja alles klar, das programmieren wir selber und es müsste so und so sein und du denkst dir halt irgendeinen Scheiß aus und wurstest dir etwas zusammen, wo 20 Minuten Google dir halt irgendeinen Algorithmus gebracht hätte, der das Problem einfach so geil löst, wie es überhaupt nur geht.
So ging es mir irgendwie Ende der 80er, da brauchte ich halt sortieren. Dann habe ich angefangen zu sortieren. Meine erste Idee war halt so Bubble Sort, aber unoptimierter Bubble Sort und dann bin ich auf die schlaue Idee gekommen, naja, wenn ich einmal den höchsten Wert suche und den hinten schon habe, dann kann ich ja meine Schleife ein Stück kleiner machen und kann den letzten Werk weglassen. Das ist die Mega Idee. Das war dann der optimierte Bubble Sort und dann so ein, zwei Jahre später hat Werner gesagt, ey du, hier Quick Sort und so. Habe ich dann jetzt mal gemacht. Das war, das konnte man gar nicht messen, wieviel das war, weil das Bubble Sort war ja sofort fertig. Da gab es nichts mehr zu messen. Da habe ich nachgeguckt, wann das Ding ist. 1960 haben die den erfunden. Also die Leute waren einfach doch früher schon auch viel schlauer als ich und man soll gucken, ob es da schon was gibt.
Ein geiles Problem war auch bei so Spielen, die wir ja machen, ist ja so Matchmaking. Also du willst jetzt sofort gegen jemand anderes spielen und der soll halt ein gleiches Level sein, so in etwa, also nicht zu weit weg halt. Das heißt, du musst irgendwie so eine Art Distanz zwischen den unterschiedlichen Spielern machen, aber weil das halt auch online ist und manche offline gehen und das ist ja auch alles dynamisch, ist ja nicht so so jetzt mal alle freest, wir gucken mal, wer es gerade online und dann sortieren wir die alle zusammen und dann spielt jetzt alle gleich. Sondern es geht ja so, die fangen an zu spielen, der eine geht offline und so weiter. Und dann haben wir halt auch überlegt, wie macht man das denn jetzt so am besten? Und dann gab es halt auch einen Algorithmus, der heißt Zlink, Nearest Neighbor, auch ein super kurzer Algorithmus eigentlich, wo du deine Distanzfunktion, also das, was der Algorithmus dann nimmt, um festzustellen, wer wie nah dran an einem anderen ist, selber definieren kannst und es war irgendwie auch so ein Paper von Anno Dutzimal und das war einfach die geile Lösung.
Die guten, alten, klassischen Algorithmen.
Und das kann ich euch nur sehr ans Herz legen, wenn ihr mal wirklich so richtig Probleme habt, also jetzt nicht den lila Button im Web-Interface, sondern Matchmaking, Mathe, alles so, so Sachen, da gibt's einfach mal die Old Farts konsultieren. Ja, diese Papers, die sind ja auch manchmal, also die von den 70er, also ich glaub, 80er, da gibt's schon viele auch in digital, aber die 70er und davor, die sind ja dann nur so schlechte Scans meistens. Da muss man...
Ich will mal diesen ganzen Knut einmal komplett zuhause haben. Da steht das doch auch alles drin.
Ja, zum Beispiel genau, diese Poisson-Verteilung, dieses Paper, was die geschrieben haben, das war halt, weil der Knut in seinen Büchern so eine Challenge geschrieben hat und meinte, das müsste man mal jemanden machen und die haben das quasi als Uni-Arbeit dann gemacht und haben das einmal so dahin gezimmert. Single Link Clustering, ist das hier der Slink? Ja, ja, da gibt es ein schönes Paper zu, auch gescannt. So, ja, jetzt.
Auch für Programmierer, die meinen, dass sie alles schon kennen und besser wissen, empfehle ich teropa.info slash Codeshapes ein kleines Quiz, was sich Source Code von Github holt und komplett so zensiert. Also, du siehst überhaupt kein einziges Zeichen, sondern du siehst quasi nur wo ein Zeichen ist und wo kein Zeichen ist. Und dann sollst du halt raten, um welche Programmiersprache es sich handelt. Das ist wirklich hardcore. Dann klickst du auf den Play-Button und wir sehen das erste Stück Code. Und ich kann schon mal sicher sagen, es ist kein C.
Also, vimel ist es auch nicht.
Warum ist es kein C?
Ja, geschweifte Klammer auf, geschweifte Klammer zu, das würde man da irgendwie... Ja, wobei es kann sein, dass es irgendwie geschweifte Klammer am Anfang ist.
Aber das sieht man irgendwie.
Das ist ein Schließen von einer Schleife.
Alles andere kann man ja gar nicht erkennen. Die Anzahl von Klammern und so würde mir... Also ich würde ja fast sagen, Closure, weil das sieht ja so aus... Ich würde eigentlich C sagen. C oder Closure.
Vimel und PowerShell kenne ich nicht.
Vimel ist es nicht.
PowerShell ist doch dieser Windows-Kram.
Mach mal Closure. Weil es ist ja alles geloopt quasi. Alles...
Nee, das ist PowerShell.
Das kann jetzt alle nicht. Zweiter Versuch. Robi, R, Perl oder Fell?
Das ist ja schon mal kein C. Das ist ja auch nicht dabei.
Klebt alles an der linken Seite.
Shell ist aber immer links.
Ja, nicht immer. Er hat schon recht. Da gibt es schon so eine Klammer zu am Ende.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es R ist, aber sonst würde ich eher sagen Perl.
Nee.
Es sind richtig dreckige Perl. Ich habe viele Perl-Programme.
Wir sind auf jeden Fall davon überzeugt, dass es nicht Robi ist. Ich würde auch nicht sagen, dass es Perl ist.
R oder Shell? Auch die langen Zeilen sind kein Perl.
Ich würde ja sagen Perl, aber R kenne ich nicht. Kann das R sein?
Es könnte, aber die Zeilen sind auch ziemlich lang. Scheiße, mach mal. Okay, wir sind ja voll nicht drauf.
Ja, genau.
Ein kurzer Pro-Tipp in die Runde, den Tim sonst immer hergibt. Wir sind ein Audiopodcast.
Die spielen ja mit. Übrigens, was wir auch letztes Mal total vergessen haben, zu erwähnen, was der Toto erwähnt hatte und was ich eigentlich auch noch sagen wollte, ist nämlich dieses Dash. Hast du das schon dir mal angerückt, Tim? Ja, ein Programm, das Dash heißt. Das ist so das Spotlight für Coding, Programmier-Doku oder was auch immer, Postgres, alles. Alles, was Tools, Hacken, Programmieren ist Fetzt. Das heißt, wo findet man das Dash? Gibt es glaube ich, gab es das nicht auch ohne App Store? Na ja, egal. Ich klicke mal hier die URL rein. Also ich war erst ein bisschen skeptisch, weil ich dachte, also erstens wollen ja auch Gelder dafür und so, ja, also ihr holt euch jetzt die Dokus von den anderen und macht nur einen kleinen Guive-Ripper drumrum, also ist ja vielleicht ein bisschen dünner. Aber dann habe ich das doch mal bei einem Kollegen gesehen und war dann doch überzeugt und habe mir das geklickt und ich benutze ja auch Alfred App und da das integriert integriert sich, wollte ich sagen, das integriert sich auch in alle möglichen App-Lounge, also auch Quicksilver Lounge Bar und man kann dann einfach so zum Beispiel kann ich tippen Erl und dann sagt er hier schon Search Erlang, mache ich Space und kann dann hier irgendwie sofort in der ganzen Standard Library und so weiter drin rum suchen und wenn er dann drauf hämmerst, dann springt er genau an die Stelle und das geht halt auch für Postgres und alle möglichen anderen Sprachen oder wie gesagt Tools, Engine X Doku was auch immer so wer es noch kennt aus früheren Zeiten, da gab es ja die Doku nur in Russisch und ein Wiki von Leuten, die das so freiwilliger Basis übersetzt haben Mittlerweile ist das gebessert, aber bei Engine X da ist die Doku immer noch so ein bisschen undurchsichtig, aber hier kann man halt auch Dann auch einfach ratten schnell nach Keywords suchen und findet sofort, was man braucht. Und quasi der erste Schritt, genau, wenn man das jetzt hier installiert ist, so dass man so seine Docs da erstmal so selektiert in Preferences, die man haben will. Und dann kannst du halt direkt anfangen, da drin rum zu suchen. Die haben halt auch alle ein Keyword. Wenn du da über das Apache rüber hovers, musst du mal gucken, ob es da, ob er dir sagt, welches Keyword das ist. Wahrscheinlich, also zum Beispiel bei Alfred App, wenn ich jetzt Apache, so wie du installiert hast, dann würde ich halt anfangen, Apache zu tippen, dann würde er schon sagen, search Dash for Apache und dann Leerzeichen und den Rest, ne. Also das wirklich, das benutze ich so viel, jetzt wenn ich in Erlang, Ruby, irgendwas nachgucken muss und das hat mir echt meinen Programmierer-Alltag und Admin-Alltag erleichtert. Kann ich nur schwerstens empfehlen, wer auf OS X fleißig am Hacken ist.
Ich hatte das auch schon länger installiert, aber ich habe es ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so viel benutzt.
Ja, das fetzt halt so richtig, wenn du benutzt der Launchbar noch, oder? Genau, wenn du das über Launchbar halt triggst, dann macht das halt einfach noch 1000 mal mehr Spaß, weil dann wirklich so einfach...
Gibt's da Jansson drin?
Gibt's da eine Integration für Lautbar?
Also das Ding kostet 19 Dollar, das war doch nicht so viel, wie ich dachte. Gibt's auch übrigens auch für IOS, kann man auch unterwegs mal gucken. Warte. Was willst du gucken?
J-N-S-S-O-N. So ein Jason Celeb.
Nee, also das ist schon, glaube ich, eher so ein bisschen... Also so die kleinen Lips sind da jetzt nicht unbedingt drin.
Das ist so für die großen Dinger, HTML, CSS und so weiter, diese ganzen Schnarres.
Aber eben auch SQL oder was auch immer. Postgres, genau. Aber auch MySQL, Engine X, wie gesagt, alles Mögliche. Genau, und diese Launchbar-Integration, die funktioniert wahrscheinlich genauso, dass du auch einfach anfängst, zum Beispiel Apache zu tippen und dann... Sicherlich...
.ist die Integration...
Automatisch.
In Launchbar ist Dash Support oder in Dash ist Launchbar?
In Dash ist Launchbar Support. Also ich glaube, man muss das auch nicht extra einschalten. Oder? Doch, warte mal, bei Integration gehen wir mal in die Preferences.
Eigentlich müsste Dash in Launchbar integriert sein.
So, Timmer.
Was denn?
Klick mal in Dash in die Preferences und da gibt's so einen Lego-Baustein oben, Integration, dann klick einfach mal auf Launchbar.
In Dash?
In Dash.
Wo soll ich da hinklicken?
Preferences.
Ah, Preferences.
Und dann Integration, klickst auf das Launchbar und passiert da was.
Ah, dann kann man eine Dash-Action. It's already installed.
Blam.
Und sogar eine neuere Version, na toll. Direkt Dash und dann, achso, okay, ich kann halt Dash und dann da suchen, alles klar.
Bei Alfred ist es halt noch ein bisschen cooler, weil du fängst eben dann an, so die Kiva zu sein, einfach Postgres und dann sagt er schon hier, und dann ist das halt nur so gescoped auf.
Aber das ist ja live, das update sich ja im Hintergrund sogar live. Das ist ja funky.
Das ist wirklich funky, cooles Tool.
Alright, haben wir's.
So, jetzt haben wir jetzt noch die Grabbekiste, ne?
Jetzt haben wir erst mal hier SSD.
Und du hast kein Bier mehr, Tim. Das finde ich ja echt ein Verdammt.
Ich hab kein Bier mehr. Das ist alle.
Nein, nur dieses komische Wurstbier da. Muss die Rohrperle sein jetzt oder was? Die Rohrperle.
Kasselberger Rohrperle.
Ich musste heute nochmal meinen Power Mac durch die Gegend fahren, deswegen habe ich leider da Zeit verloren.
Excuses, nothing but excuses.
Ist es jetzt wieder heile?
Ja, es hat sich von alleine repariert.
Durch die Gegend fahren?
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Also ernsthaft. Weil ich war ja irgendwie SSD-Kabel unklar und so weiter. Und ich hab's irgendwie beim Fuchs auf den Tisch gestellt und die haben mich nur doof angeguckt und gesagt, welches Problem? Und jetzt funktioniert's wieder ganz magisch. Da kommt man sich schon ein bisschen bekloppt vor. Naja, dafür habe ich jetzt zwei Terabyte SSDs drin und frage mich, was ich mit der zweiten mache. Mache ich mir noch mal ein Terra dazu und nutze das für irgendwas? Oder mirrore ich die? Ich habe jetzt so eine neue Samsung 850 da drin und die macht hier immerhin geschmeidige 260 MB pro Sekunde. Was?
So langsam. Erstens ist es nur SATA 2, da sieht man das schon mal. 260 MB, bei mehr als 280 geht da nämlich nicht. Hättest du SATA 3, wärst du schon mal bei 500. Und hättest du so ein PCI-Slot, dann wärst du bei 1400.
Mit den Platten?
Nee, das ist ja eine SATA-Platt. Aber 500 hättest du schon. SATA 3 kann du auf jeden Fall.
Ja.
Womit wir ja schon mal im Thema werden.
Genau.
Weil jetzt, hast du denn schon den Trim-Enabler?
Nicht?
Also wer es noch nicht kennt, aber ich denke, die meisten in der SSD am Kennz, aber wahrscheinlich auch viele nicht. Apple unterstützt dieses Trim-Commando, was dafür sorgt, dass, wenn die Platte voll wird, dass man trotzdem schnell schreiben kann, weil die Blöcke vorgelöscht werden, so muss man das sagen bei einer SSD. Unterstützt Apple nur bei seinen eigenen SSDs, die in einer ID mit Apple anfangen. Eine Samsung-Platte fängt halt nicht mit Apple an in einer ID und dann unterstützt Apple da keinen Trim. Und da gibt es ein Tool bis Yosemite, das heißt Trim Enabler, der ändert so eine Kernel-Extension so, dass nicht mehr nach Apple geguckt wird, sondern das wird einfach immer aktiviert. Das Problem unter Yosemite ist nur, das hatten wir auch alles schon mal in der Sendung, dass die Kernel-Extensions jetzt signiert sind und man das nicht mehr so ändern kann, außer man schaltet die Signierung, also das Checken der Signaturen komplett aus fürs ganze OS und das ist natürlich auch wieder nicht so schön.
Und man kann sich halt auch schön auslocken damit.
Und man kann sich auslocken damit, indem man, wenn man diese Signierung aus Versehen wieder einschaltet, zum Beispiel durch ein Parameter-Rem-Reset, dann ist ja diese Kernel-Extension, dann ist die ja nicht mehr gültig, weil die Signatur stimmt ja nicht mehr und die sorgt aber, dass man von der Platte lesen kann. Also kann man nicht mehr von der Platte lesen, bang, ist man im Arsch. Und jetzt hat Apple ja den El Capitan rausgegeben und die Leute, die nehmen das immer gleich von vorne bis hinten auseinander und gucken, was sich geändert hat und so weiter. Und dann gibt es da ein Kommando. Scheiße, ich habe jetzt vergessen, wie es heißt. Ich kann das kurz mal checken hier. Das hieß irgendwas mit Trim. Trim Force. Man kann das Trim einfach einschalten. Man muss seinen Rechner kurz vorher in den Ruthless Mode schalten, wo ich immer noch nicht genau weiß, was es genau ist. Dann schaltet man mit Trim Force dieses Trim ein und danach kann man den Ruthless Mode auch wieder ausschalten. Und dann hat man jetzt Trim Support für SSDs, die auch nicht von Apple sind. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt bei dir auch ohne diesen Trim Enabler Hack zu benutzen, kannst du jetzt Trim für deine Platten einschalten.
Wenn der Kapitän draußen ist?
Wenn der Kapitän draußen ist, ja.
Und dein Setup auf dem Kapitän funktioniert?
Tut es, weil Kapitän läuft überall da, wo Yosemite auch läuft.
Hast du schon mal irgendwie konkrete Auswirkungen davon, dass du diesen Trim Enabler benutzt nachweisen können oder dass man ihn nicht benutzt? Also ich meine, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie 260 MB habe...
Das ist schwierig. Solange du deine Terabyte-Platte hast, wenn du die kaufst, dann ist die ja vorgelöscht. Die ist ja sozusagen schon getrimmt, könnte man so sagen. Das heißt, bis du wenigstens einmal vollgeschrieben hast, spielt das ja noch keine Rolle. Dann kommt noch dazu, dass die modernen SSDs oder auch schon seit Jahren, die haben eine sogenannte Garbage Collection. Der merkt sich ja, was überschrieben wurde und der macht dieses Löschen der Blöcke, macht er intern auch schon. Nur kann es nicht so perfekt machen, weil er weiß nicht so hundertprozentig, wann du was gelöscht hast. Weil das File-System sagt ihm das ja nicht. Wenn du was löscht, wird ja nur der Eintrag aus der Directory entfernt, aber die Daten bleiben ja liegen, da kann die Platte nicht wissen, dass du jetzt dein File gelöscht hast. Deswegen ist diese Garbage Collection nicht ganz so perfekt. Die wurde über die Jahre zwar besser, und die ist schon ziemlich gut, und man kann auch ohne fahren, aber mit Trim ist halt immer noch mal so ein Stück besser. Ob man das messen kann, das kann ich dir nicht sagen, aber ich benutze das, weil es...
Ich habe das bei diversen Kollegen tatsächlich in der Firma schon mal beobachtet. Die haben sich halt so mehr oder weniger darüber beschwert, dass ihre Platte immer langsamer wurde, oder ihre SSD, die war halt nicht mehr so spritzig wie am Anfang. Und die Platten waren noch meistens ran voll, weil die ersten SSDs die waren jetzt auch noch nicht so groß und teuer. Und dann haben wir denen auch immer den Trim-Enabler drauf gekloppt, haben mal irgendwelche großen Dateien gelöscht sozusagen, und danach war das schon deutlich spürbar besser.
Genau. Weil das OS schickt jetzt der Plattenkommando hier. Ich habe folgende Datei gelöscht, die ist 1 GB groß, die liegt da, da und da. Und die kannst du jetzt wegmachen. Und dann kann die SSD, während gerade auf deinem Rechner nichts los ist oder wenn die Platte nicht macht, fängt an, diese Blöcke schon mal vor zu löschen, weil eine SSD ist zwar sehr schnell beim Schreiben, aber dazu muss der Block halt gelöscht sein. Du kennst es vielleicht von EEPROMS früher, die musste man ja erst löschen, bevor man sie beschreiben konnte. Und das ist so ein bisschen ähnlich.
Aber warum bauen sie das jetzt ein und warum haben sie das noch nicht vorher eingebaut?
Doch, das ist ja schon drin, aber sie haben es, weil es nicht ganz problemfrei ist, nur für ihre eigenen Platten freigegeben.
Ja, aber was hat sich jetzt auf einmal geändert?
Ich denke mal, denen hat das nicht gefallen, dass die Leute jetzt alle in diesem Developer Mode irgendwie ihr OS fahren und diese Signaturen ausschalten.
Den Trim-Enabler zu betreiben.
Da nehme ich dann doch so viele, weil der Trim-Enabler hat das für dich auch übernommen. Früher hat der Trim-Enabler nur die Körner- Extension gepatcht und hat gesagt, mach einen Neustart, damit er geladen wird. Und inzwischen macht der Trim-Enabler aber auch gleich alles klar. Ich mach das mit dem Signieren-Checken, mir füll dich auch gleich aus und so. Und ich glaube, das war denen ein bisschen zu weit. Vielleicht schützen sie da auch mit ihrer eigenen Pfaffe. Haben sie überlegt, naja, das ist jetzt nicht so mega wichtig. Wir wollen unsere Leute ja schützen, bevor der nächste große Virus kommt und alle den kriegen, weil sie nicht eine SSD von Apple haben.
Vielleicht haben sie auch gesehen, dass da einfach so und so viele Millionen Leute diesen Trim-Enabler drauf haben und das geht und dass das jetzt gar nicht so ein großes Problem ist, sondern haben sie gesagt, naja, gut, dann bitte, die mal gessen.
Ich meine, das ist doch ein Standard-Kommando von SSDs. Das ist doch nicht anders, als die anderen.
Aber die stellen ja jetzt ihre ganze Rechnerlein mehr oder weniger auf fest verlötetes SSD um.
Da ist das ja eigentlich dann wurscht.
Also, kauf mal noch einen Rechner, wo du dir eine SSD selber reinstecken kannst.
Die alten Früten sind für Bustler, die sollen halt ruhig rumtrimmen.
Und vielleicht liegt es auch daran, weil wie in Fefe Bild ja stand, gibt es ja auch SSDs, die das irgendwie nicht so richtig mit klarkommen oder wo irgendwie komische Sachen passieren. Hast du das gelesen in der Artikel?
Genau, da hatte so ein...
Da hat bestimmte Samsung-SSDs, die dann doch mal mit dem Trimmen nicht so richtig klarkommen.
Die Geschichte war halt, dass so ein großes Platform, was auch immer, die hatten halt so Lochfraß auf ihren SSDs und konnten sich das nicht erklären. Dann haben sie sich vor einem X-File-System zum Kernel alles mal angeguckt haben dann festgestellt, dass es da eine Whitelist oder eine Blacklist gibt für bestimmte SSD-Modelle und Hersteller, wo Trim geht. Ich glaube, es war... Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, warum es war. Auf jeden Fall, wenn es nicht da drin war, dann haben sie auf Trim undefaultet und das hat bei bestimmten Samsung-SSDs dafür gesorgt, dass die halt irgendwie Lochfraß hatten.
Die haben halt gelinkelig auch mal so ein Superblatt gelöscht, was sozusagen der Tod deines Fallsystems ist.
Und ja...
Macht dir keine Sorgen, es war die 840 und nicht die 850, die du hast.
Doch, war auch eine 850 mit dabei. Ja, stand in der Liste mit drin. Aber macht dir keine Sorgen, du hast eh ein super stabiliertes Fallsystem, nämlich HFS+, deswegen kann dir da nichts passieren.
Wohin wir wieder bei ZFS werden? Weil da würde das wirklich nicht passieren, weil dieser sogenannte Überblock, der so ein bisschen Superblock vergleichbar ist, der liegt da mehrfach auf der Platte und dann würde einfach ein anderer genommen werden.
Und man kann sogar sagen, dass man noch mehr Kopien davon haben will.
Habt ihr diesen Artikel gesehen auf Heise? Der ist schon ein paar Tage her. Man sollte seine SSDs heiß betreiben und kalt lagern. Also, sie haben irgendwie bessere Ergebnisse, Bits zu erhalten auf SSDs, die nicht in Betrieb sind, wenn sie irgendwie runterkühlen. Das war dann noch mal die empfohlene Geschichte.
Es ist ohnehin interessant, was Leute, die von irgendwas ein paar mehr betreiben, immer für Stories zu erzählen haben. Egal, ob jetzt Festplatten sind oder SSDs oder sonst sowas.
Da gibt es doch diese berühmte Paper von Google über ihre Festplatten. Wenn Platten sterben, dann gleich oder gar nicht, oder nach fünf Jahren dann erst. Aber so Burn-in musst du machen. Wenn es so einen Monat hält, dann hält die auch ganz lange.
Mein Freund von mir ist für die Infrastruktur zuständig, wo auch das Internet archivt, sein ganzes Zeug auf irgendwelche Platten donnert. Und er hat einen Mitarbeiter, der hat jeden Morgen die Routine, durch das Restenzählen zu tapern und die kaputten Platten einzusammeln durch neue auszutauschen.
Und der hat jeden Tag zu tun.
Der hat jeden Tag zu tun, hat Dutzende von Festplatten, die er dort rennt, sozusagen mit dem Körbchen von neuen Festplatten durch die Gegend, guckt vor die rote Lampe alles an, er rät, tut eine neue Platte rein, und zwar wirklich Dutzende, jeden Tag.
Ja, so muss es sein. Und dann am besten noch muss es so passieren, dass er nichts weiter machen muss, außer rausziehen und die nächste reinstecken und das fixt sich dann alles von alleine, ohne dass er noch mal irgendwo an das Software ran. Oh, und ich hab jetzt bestimmt das EMC-Quadrat, oder?
Nein, nein, nein. Ich will nicht sagen Billo, aber das ist homegrown, weil so was wie EMC-Quadrat wollen, die sich gar nicht leisten. Das ist auch übrigens nicht alles nur Gold. Das ist alles schön handgeklöppelt.
Von der Festplatte zum Rastelektronen-Mikroskop. Ich hab da schon echt lange drauf gewartet. Ich wollte das schon immer mal sehen, wie das aussieht, wenn hier die Nadel bei so einer Schallplatte in der Rille groovt. Da hat sich jetzt mal einer die Mühe gemacht und hat eine Schallplatte zerstökelt, eine CD zerstökelt, eine DVD und auch noch so eine analoge Video-Disc, die irgendwie schon dead on arrival war, als sie in der Produktion fertig war. Und er zeigt auch in dem Video, wie er das da in dieses Mikroskop reingeklebt hat und wie er dieses animierte Gift gemacht hat. Der hat natürlich nicht jetzt so das Mikroskop auf so eine Schallplatte halten können, sondern er hat sozusagen den Arm und die Rillen, das Rillenstück quasi separat aufgehangen und hat dann den Arm immer 50 Mikrons weiter bewegt und ein Foto gemacht, weil im Live-Bild ist die Auflösung halt nicht gut genug von so einem Mikroskop, der muss halt so einen richtigen Scan machen, der 10 Sekunden dauert. Dann hat er das halt wirklich so Frame für Frame quasi da.
Also so Stop-Motion im Mikron-Bereich.
Und in dem Video, was jetzt hier im Chat hoffentlich schon auch verlinkt wurde und später in den Show Notes, da seht ihr auch, wie er eine CD dann halt zerlegt und dann sieht man halt auch schön zum Beispiel diese Videodisc, die hat eine extrem krasse hohe Datendichte im Vergleich zu der Schallplatte auch schon und er erklärt halt auch super schön, wie er so die einzelnen Sachen auseinander nimmt, damit das überhaupt in dieses Mikroskop reinpasst. Und später guckt er sich dann eben auch eine CD an und dann kann man halt mal diese Bits quasi in dieser Alufolie sehen und bei einer DVD, wie hoch dann die Datendichte im Vergleich dazu ist und wo dann das Mikroskop auch an die Grenzen der Auflösung stößt, sozusagen. Und das ist echt so ein cooles Video. Ich finde das ja immer, genau, hier ist wie so die beiden Ebenen sozusagen nach dem Mikroskop so aneinanderjustiert werden, damit er ein schönes Bild davon kriegt. Also was ist... Er hat halt hier so ein, genau, er hat so ein Interface dafür gleich und jetzt macht er hier so einmal so schön diesen, ach das sieht so geil aus, mit so einem grünen Röhrenmonitor geht er der Scan-Streifen.
Das ist ja ein richtig altes Teil.
Ja genau und hier das ist das Interface, um jetzt sozusagen die Ebenen sozusagen immer so ein paar Microns weiter zu drehen. Und genau, das könnt ihr euch mal angucken, das ist ganz schick und der erklärt das halt auch gut. Ich finde das ja immer geil, wenn die Wissenschaftler halt mal so allgemein Gegenstände auseinandernehmen und mal genauer hingucken, wenn sie mal ein bisschen Freizeit haben. Und besonders schön fand ich auch, dass das halt so ein bisschen Hacker-Value hat, weil er erklärt halt auch oder versucht halt von der DVD diese gepresste Schicht von dem Plastik und dem Coating zu lösen und fummelt halt so ein bisschen rum und kriegt es nicht hin und dann am Ende meint er, ja, was es dann getan hat, nehmt einfach starkes Duct Tape. Genau, klebt das drauf und dann reißt es ganz schnell ab und dann hast du halt die Alufolie an dem Duct Tape dran und vorher hat er irgendwie versucht, das da so auseinanderzuschnibbeln und aufzulösen und so weiter und so fort. Und ja, so kann man sich das mal ein bisschen verbildlichen. Und er erklärt auch, wie Stereo auf der Schallplatte funktioniert. Das wusste ich nämlich vorher auch nicht. Und das Video ist echt so 10 Minuten lang oder so, aber es steckt voller cooler, kleiner...
Na, wer erklärt, wie Stereo funktioniert?
Guckt euch das Video an. Ich kann das jetzt nicht so gut nachwiedergehen.
Also, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, dann ist die eine Spur, also Mono, da war, wenn die Nadel links, rechts bewegt wird und durch die Achse dann in so Magneten wird irgendwie Strom erzeugt oder...
Ja, so hätte ich es jetzt auch erklären können.
Ja, warte, das ist Mono und Stereo ist halt, wie die Nadel sich hoch und runter bewegt.
Nee, ist aber nicht so.
Hat er doch auch so gesagt.
Also, es ist versetzt. Guckt euch das selber an. Nee, das ist kein Spoiler, wir haben ja keine Ahnung, könnt schlecht nacherzählen. Guckt euch selber an, wenn ihr die Wahrheit wissen wollt.
Am Montag war übrigens im Club eine Rasterelektronen-Mikroskop vorführen, weil wir haben jetzt so ein Ding im Keller.
Das läuft jetzt auch?
Schon lange. Nur weiß halt immer aus, dass da aber keiner, wie das Ding funktioniert, deswegen gemachte ich da mal Vorführungen. Weil da kann man nicht einfach mal so loslegen, weil es ja schon auch mit krasser Vakuumpumpe und so weiter und so fort.
Und was habt ihr mikroskopiert? Gras?
Ich war nicht dabei. Nee, wie der ja auch schon erzählt hat, du kannst nur Sachen da reinlegen, die halt metallisch bedampft sind, weil nur dann das System funktioniert. Das heißt, du müsstest erst alles bedampfen, was der ja sich da selber gebaut hat, indem er da irgendwie silber draufdampft. Sowas haben wir im Club leider nicht, aber Starbuck will ja eh nur Chips irgendwie scannen, Rasse, Elektronenmikroskop und da ist ja schon Metall. Aber sonst, wenn du so Tierchen scannen willst, dann müsstest du erst mal mit Metall bedampfen.
So, wir nähern uns langsam dem Ende. Wie geht es dem Huckel?
Ein Thema musst du noch packen, dann hast du es geschafft.
Ja geil, hier spät hier oder was? Warnisch ist ein Programm, das ist geil, weil es ist von einem Menschen geschrieben, der doch schon eine gute Historie hat. Paul Henning Kamm, könnt ihr mal googeln. Der hat schon einiges auf dem Kerbholz.
Duck, Erling, Smorgraph oder wie heißt der Typ?
War es jetzt Warnisch oder Hitch?
Jetzt warte doch mal.
Die Spannung zerreißt mich.
Wer Warnisch nicht kennt, das ist ein Tool, das man vor seine Webseite knallen kann. Zum Beispiel ein Wordpress und das macht das Caching und zwar in so Performant, wie es irgendwie nur geht. Also Warnisch ist so eine Software, die saturiert dir Leitungen, wenn du sie lässt oder wenn du auch, da bin ich noch nie an der Performance-Grenze gestoßen. Geile Software. So, und jetzt haben alle gesagt, ja, geile Software, geile Caching-Software, aber kannst du nicht uns SSL-Terminierung mit einbauen? Dann hat Paul Henning Kamm, wie er das so üblicherweise macht, einen Blogpost mal zugeschrieben und hat mal kurz, also er rantet nicht so wirklich, aber er hat schon auch so einen Alphanerd-mäßigen Duktus in seinen Formulierungen, sag ich mal, und hat auch meistens Recht damit und hat gesagt, nee, mach ich nicht. Dieses Tool macht eine Sache und die macht sich verdammt gut und ich borde jetzt nicht irgendein kaputtes SSL-Gedöns rein und was wir eigentlich immer alle ganz gut finden. Und jetzt kam aber ein neues Produkt heraus, Hitch heißt das, und das ist quasi auch so aus diesem Warnisch-Universum, also das glaube ich auch auf der Webseite der Blogpost veröffentlicht. Es ist nicht von Paul Henning Kamm entwickelt, aber der hat scheinbar das so gut gefunden, dass er das da in sein Warnisch-Universum mit aufgenommen hat. Und sie versprechen halt, dass das das Beste ist seit geschnittenen SSL. Und irgendwie performt wie Hölle. Also ich benutze ja hier bei VUGA, H-Aproxy hatte ich ja auch schon mal erzählt, die haben ja auch irgendwann SSL-Tunnel, Codebase, ne wie heißt das SSL? Dieses kleine Tool, was auch SSL... S-Tunnel. Ne, irgendwas anderes vergesse ich gerade. Also H-Aproxy hat ja auch SSL-Terminierungen eingebaut und auch sehr performant. Das ist zum Beispiel was GitHub benutzt für ihre SSL-Terminierungen. Und das soll also noch tollerer sein sogar. Aber ja, das wollte ich nur mal so erwähnt haben, weil so eine Tools, die sind halt immer oft unter dem Radar und wenn man halt mal anfängt, ein cooles Produkt zu haben oder eine tolle Webseite, dann kommen so eine Fragen immer zum genau falschen Zeitpunkt, weil man dann einfach so ja, hier mach mal einfach SSL an, passt schon. Und dann hat man sich quasi selber direkt in den Ofen geschossen, weil man muss sich damit ein bisschen befassen.
Performance dann auch zu kriegen.
Ja, so ein ganz übliches Problem ist so, wie lange ist die SSL-Session und wie lange dürfen so Connections aufbleiben, weil zum Beispiel üblicherweise so Mobiltelefone, die haben halt einfach Latenz und so, ne? Die halten so eine Connection einfach endlos lange offen im Zweifel. Und dann ist halt irgendwie auch der letzte Port irgendwann mal dicht und dann hast du halt deine eigene Büchse quasi, dir gededost mit einem, sagen wir mal, suboptimalen SSL-Setup. Und das geht aber mittlerweile alles viel besser. Also früher brauchte man halt so fette Load-Balancer-Maschinen, so richtig teure, millionenschwere Maschinen. Heutzutage können das schon die ganzen Server-CPUs ziemlich gut selber. Man muss es halt nur einigermaßen gut konfigurieren. Und mit HAProxy und jetzt eben mit Hitch gibt es zwei richtig gute Alternativen. Also ich vermute einfach mal, dass dieses Hitch mindestens genauso so einen nackten, metallenden Eindruck wie dieses Warnisch macht in Sachen Performance. Also hast du schon mal Warnisch benutzt?
Nee, ich hab keine Anwendung dafür bisher gehabt.
Ich hab das benutzt.
Ich bastel auch viel mit HAProxy und so, aber also das ist wirklich, also ein Caching.
Und dann dieses VCL, was dann auch war, dieser Pseudoscript, oder was die da hatten, womit man auch in Metal Speed auch noch irgendwie Sachen filtern oder weiß schon anpassen kann. Aber als ich das benutzt hab, da hatte noch so ein paar Sachen, die waren komisch. Also das war halt die 1.0, war halt noch sehr jung. Aber ich dachte mir, geiles neues Zeug will ich haben.
Nee, das ist wirklich, also ich hab das bei VUGA auch schon ein, zwei Mal für so Sachen benutzt und wenn dann halt mal so die ganze Welt so draufhämmert, weil irgendwie eine blöde Pressemitteilung überall oder irgendwelche Werbung geschaltet ist und das Ding sitzt da halt so mit 10% CPU und macht halt den Link dicht. Das ist wirklich toll.
Und lasst mich raten, es waren gar keine 10%, es waren viel weniger.
Nee, es waren so 10, 12, waren es schon.
Da hat es aber schon gekweimt, ordentlich auf den Lagen, oder?
Gut, zum Schluss noch zwei potentielle Schließmeldungen. Die eine hat schon stattgefunden. Vimedio, also known as Martin Hering, hier zu Gast bei damals noch Mobile Max 107.
Wer erinnert sich nicht.
Genau. Autor von zahlreichen Apps, genau wie Instacast zum Beispiel für iOS und den Mac und jüngst irgendwie Snowflake und Snowtape und so weiter. Also diverse, echt coole Tools. Hat jetzt da Konsequenzen daraus gezogen, dass es ihm irgendwie nicht gelungen ist, da richtig Geld zu verdienen mit dem ganzen Betrieb.
Geht jetzt auch zu Facebook.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was er macht. Ich habe auch jetzt nicht mit ihm im Detail darüber gesprochen. Ich bin ein bisschen vorgewarnt gewesen und von daher nicht so überrascht gewesen, dass es stattfindet. Aber ich wusste, dass ich das irgendwie abzeichne oder dass er das zumindest erwägt. Das kam dann noch ein bisschen schneller, als ich dachte. Ich hoffe, dass zumindest noch so die ganzen Infrastrukturen noch eine Weile laufen. Aber Tatsache ist, dass uns Instacast jetzt mittelfristig wegbricht als doch sehr kapabler Podcast.
Kapabler, ist das wirklich ein Wort?
Das kommt noch dazu. Also wir haben ja mit PodLav auch sehr viel mit Martin zusammengearbeitet. Und er hat irgendwie viele Sachen umgesetzt. Und wir haben viele Sachen gemeinsam unterhalten. Insofern ist das wirklich jetzt auch ein großer Verlust. Gut, das mag jetzt nicht jeder immer mit allem glücklich gewesen sein. Niemand ist mit jeder Software zufrieden. Das ist ganz klar. Aber im Wesentlichen hat das wirklich sehr geholfen. Und war nach wie vor mein Tool der Wahl. Da höre ich auch immer noch irgendwie meine Podcasts mit. Und es war irgendwie feature-complete. Und ich finde das sehr bedauerlich, dass es so weit gekommen ist. Aber es war nicht mehr so einfach. Also insbesondere die Konkurrenz von Overcast und vielleicht auch anderen Clients wie Pocketcast. Das weiß ich im Einzelnen nicht. Aber da ist der Wettbewerb doch enorm angezogen in letzter Zeit. Dazu halt noch mit den chronisch niedrigen Preisen und Leuten, die halt irgendwie sofort anfangen, Zeta und Morioh zu schreiben, wenn du mal irgendwie nach einem Dollar fragst. Das ist schon auch ein bisschen hardcore. Dazu kommt halt noch Apples bekloppte App Store-Politik mit der Unmöglichkeit, Upgrades zu machen, was ich ehrlich gesagt bis heute nicht so richtig verstehe. Also ich verstehe nicht, was die Motivation dahinter ist und finde das auch falsch. Ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das so seht, aber...
Hatten wir ja schon diskutiert, ich glaube, da herrscht Einstimmigkeit.
Ja, genau. Das heißt, es ist einfach sehr schwierig, auf so einem Markt irgendwie zu bestehen. Das fängt schon damit an, dass die meisten Apps jetzt irgendwie als, ja, ich bin jetzt erstmal kostenlos und man kann mich auch schon mal benutzen. Wenn man mich besonders lieb hat, dann kauft man noch mal was. So hat das ja bei Overcast zum Beispiel gemacht. Oder man hat irgendwelche Backend-Dienste, die man sich bezahlen lässt, Syncing oder ähnliche Geschichten. Klar, im Nachhinein kann man da immer alles besser wissen. Aber so eine, ja, so was aufrecht zu halten, ich fand das ehrlich gesagt ziemlich bemerkenswert, was der da alles an Infrastruktur hat. Also eine App entwickeln ist schon mal eins, weil du ja permanent immer wieder neue Features einbauen musst, permanent jedem OS wechseln entgegen Fiebers, um sozusagen da App Store kompatibel zu sein. Dann das ganze Web-Backend und ähnliche Geschichten, Top-Listen, dann noch den Mac-Client dazu. Das war halt einfach eine Menge Arbeit und irgendwie hat es halt nicht gereicht. Das kann natürlich auch sein. Hat den Ferrari nicht mehr bezahlt.
Ja, oder er konnte sich dann hier –wie heißt die Top-Notch –Apple Watch?
Watch App war ja auch noch dran. Wie auch immer, ich wollte nur deshalb aufgreifen, weil natürlich auch sofort viele Leute gefragt haben, na ja, könnte man jetzt nicht hier Open Source machen und sollte nicht einen eigenen Podcast klein entwickeln, etc., pp.? Also, Code, der nicht für Open Source gemacht ist zu Open Sourcen, ist meistens vergebliche Liebesmüh. Also das ist schon mal das eine. Also grundsätzlich sehe ich das nicht. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass das irgendwie groß helfen würde, weil sich in anderer Leute Code reinzulesen, das kostet mehr Zeit, als es selber zu schreiben. Also das ist, oder?
In den meisten Fällen, ja.
In den meisten Fällen ist es so. Es sei denn, es wäre von vornherein halt so angelegt und dokumentiert worden, dass es sozusagen jederzeit auf Schnapp von irgendjemand anders übernommen werden kann. Ehrlich gesagt, einen Mobile-Podcast-Client zu entwickeln, da gehört echt einiges dazu. Zumal ja der Trend auch ganz klar dahin geht, dass man eben auch ein eigenes Syncing-Backend braucht. Das heißt, man muss ja auch eine enorme Expertise aufbringen. Also man muss nicht nur in der Lage sein, so eine App gut zu entwickeln und da sich Features auszudenken, umzusetzen und Apps rauszuhauen, sondern man muss halt auch noch eine komplette Web-Backend-Infrastruktur mit dazu machen. Auch das liegt nicht unbedingt jedem. So sehr ich sowas gerne bauen wollen würde, ich selber kann es nicht, aber auch Leute dafür zu finden, die bereit sind, sowas zu machen, vor allem als Open-Source-Projekt, ist schwierig. Gut, jetzt mag der eine oder andere sich da vielleicht anbieten. Letzten Endes ist das halt einfach eine enorme Maßnahme, wo ich das einfach gerade nicht sehe, wie man das umsetzt. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen schade, aber gut, wer sich jetzt schon nach Alternativen umschauen mag, also aus PodLav-Perspektive gibt es zumindest PodCat von der Jeanette Müller, was auch ein ganz pfiffiger Client ist, der eine ganze Menge auch PodLav-Features mit drin hat. Im Vergleich zu Instacast fehlen mir da persönlich noch so ein paar Sachen wie Suche etc., aber das entwickelt sich zumindest ganz gut, das Tool. Und ansonsten müssen wir halt mal schauen, dass wir jetzt auch sehen, dass wir die Zusammenarbeit mit anderen kleinen Developern verstärken. Nicht alle reagieren da immer so, wie es mir recht wäre. Und wenn ihr sozusagen an einem Podcast-Line dran seid, auch für andere Plattformen und so, dann meldet euch mal. Mehr kann ich da eigentlich nicht zu sagen. Ist traurig, aber ist so. Ein kleiner Downer jetzt hier noch am Schluss. Aber wir retten jetzt nochmal.
Genau, rettet die Spätis. In Berlin zumindest. Lokal Patriotismus angesagt. Die CDU, wohl im Speziellen, die findet das total unkorrekt, dass die ganzen Spätis in Berlin das Gesetz brechen, in dem sie nicht nur erstens sonntags geöffnet haben, sondern auch zweitens Alkohol und Tabak verkauft haben. Sie sehen sich bemüht. Jetzt ziehen schon das Ordnungsamt hin und wieder durch die Straßen und drücken so den Spätis ein fettes Bußgeld auf. Das sieht man daran, dass manche Spätis sonntags nicht aufhaben. Die Seite ist übrigens sehr langsam. Und die wollen tatsächlich das wohl so regeln, dass das in Zukunft unterbleibt. Und auch das Tankstellen, zum Beispiel, kein Alkohol und Tabak mehr am Sonntag verkaufen.
Berlin wird endlich christlich.
Ja genau, geht aber gar nicht.
Ist die ISIS schon da oder was?
Ich hab schon gehört, dass es auch schon eine kleine Demo dazu gab. Die hab ich aber zu spät davon verpasst erfahren. Und jetzt gab es so eine Petition auf change.org. Das war die Seite, in der wir in Episode, welche war es denn noch gleich? Moment, ich guck gerade mal. In Freak Show 105 schon mal so vorsichtig gewarnt haben, weil die sehr viele Newsletter raus schicken. Die kann man ja dann wieder abbestellen. Auf jeden Fall gibt es da eine Petition, um schon mal so ein bisschen Unterschriften oder digitale Unterschriften zu sammeln, um dem Bürgermeister von Berlin, den ich noch nie gesehen habe und noch nie ein Wort von ihm gehört habe, zu sagen, dass wir das prinzipiell scheiße finden. Und wir wollen, dass die Spätis in Berlin noch mehr Rechte bekommen als ohnehin schon.
Ich sagte, genau, was dahinter steckt, ist die Kühlschrankindustrie. Weil hier in den Gegenden, wo die Leute Spätis haben, hat doch keiner einen Kühlschrank. Weil wenn du was hast, gehst du dann runter, gehst du in den Späti.
Ich packe jetzt mal die URLs dieser Petition rein. Aber ich sage mal so, die Petition alleine, die wird es wahrscheinlich auch nicht reißen. Also die Seite ist auch ein bisschen langsam. Manchmal klickt da mal drauf, wenn ihr da ein Interesse habt als Berliner. Und ansonsten haltet mal Ohren und Augen. Offenfalls gibt es doch mal so Demos zu dem Thema und andere Aktionen, dass man sich da auch präsentiert. Weil wirklich, das ist Teil Lebensqualität in dieser Stadt.
Ich bin auch gerade vollkommen verwirrt, weil ich dachte eigentlich tatsächlich, das sei hier irgendwie anders geregelt.
Es ist geduldet, wie vieles in der Stadt.
Du glaubst gar nicht, was diese Stadt an Spießertum hervorbringen kann.
Das ist ja grausam.
Ab und zu kommen so Leute aus den Außenbezirken. Kommen denn so aus Zehlendorf?
Oder aus Panken oder aus dem Schwabenland. Also mit WoWi wäre das nicht passiert.
Und rennen dann so in der Innenstadt rum und babbeln immer nur und alles mit unseren Steuergeldern, alles mit unseren Steuergeldern, alles mit unseren Steuergeldern. Da muss man was gegen tun. Ja, weil interessiert zwar, wie gesagt, das geht seit Jahren, interessiert doch keine Sau, tut doch keinem weh, aber dann muss man denn nochmal was dagegen unternehmen. Sonst wären wir ja auch nicht deutsch.
Naja, auf der anderen Seite hab ich gehört, dass jetzt die Anträge von der Bürgermeisterin an Kreuzberg zu dieser Coffee-Shop-Thematik wohl voll vor der Verendung und Abgabe stehen. Insofern gibt es dann vielleicht zwar keine Spätis mehr am Donnerstag, aber... Jetzt bin ich aber auch... Also rettet die Spätis bitte.
Genau.
Du müsst auch nicht in Berlin wohnen.
Rettet die Podcast-Lines und zahlt immer schön brav für Software, weil sonst endet es.
Und spendet für die Wikipedia.
Genau. Und spendet für die Freak Show. Die ist auch sehr bedürftig.
Und für Auto.
Und sie ist müde. Die Freak Show. Jetzt haben wir hier 8 Stunden in 8 Tagen abgeliefert. Das muss jetzt erstmal wieder eine Weile reichen.
Warte nicht nächste Woche wieder.
Na jetzt ist die Themenlist aber erstmal, also die ist jetzt schon...
Wir generieren einfach noch Themen. Und dann machen wir Pause bis Oktober.
Eine ganz kleine, geringe Chance, dass wir tatsächlich in zwei Wochen doch noch eine neue Sendung machen können.
Das wäre?
Das wäre der 1. Juli.
Nö, echt nicht.
Kann ich aber an der Stelle noch nicht bestätigen. Werden wir dann sehen.
Diese Angaben sind wie immer ohne Gewähr.
Genau, das sowieso. Ansonsten, vielen Dank für Anna-Lena, für Kommentare.
Nur mal kurz winkenderweise dazwischen gesprochen.
Und für die Sittenwacht.
Für die Sittenwacht, dass du aufgepasst hast auf uns. Dass wir hier nicht durchdrehen.
Ich war mäßig erfolgreich.
Ist auch schwierig.
So sind wir.
Hat noch keiner geschafft.
Ein Käfig voller Narren. Genau, und viel Erfolg bei deinem Projekt. So, und das war's Leute. Jetzt machen wir hier Schluss. Sack zu, und alles ist vorbei. Freak Show. Wir... Moment. Verschieden uns.
Und der Pro B am Werk. Die ganze Aufzeichnung ist kaputt. Hattest du denn einen Film drin?
Wir wollten eigentlich ein anderes Outro machen.
Achso, ist egal. Nee, passt schon.